and it would be good uh for those uh who
are not familiar with what um an
employee assistance program does if you
could just give us a paragraph on what
the what the purpose is of that
program um Mr chairman and members of
division 3 house finance for the record
my name is John Williams I'm the
director of legislative affairs for the
New Hampshire Department of Health and
Human Services and with me today
is thank you I'm Michael laws I'm the
director for the state of New
Hampshire's employee assistance program
and Mr Alis will um proceed in
addressing your initial question or um
request for a highlevel brief overview
of what this program would
do so State uh Employee Assistance
programs are really designed to support
employees with whatever challenges that
they may be dealing with in the uh in
the workplace or even outside of the
workplace it's not intended to be
long-term Services they're brief in
nature um uh there can be an educational
component but for the most part what it
really entails in brief is an assessment
of some of the challenges that the
individual is dealing with maybe some
resources or connecting with resources
out in the community in those specific
areas in in the corporate world um the
other thing that I think happened in uh
Employee Assistance programs it was also
um gave some insight into um the Health
and Welfare of the workforce and if
there were unusual stresses building in
the aggregate to inform management that
there may be some systemic issues that
would should be addressed does does our
state EAP do anything like that our our
EAP is really a robust program program
in that it works with individuals with
their individual needs but there are
also places for workplace
interventions um work culture audits
just a variety of supports and services
to impact the employee health and
wellness as you mentioned but also in
some circumstances dependent on how the
ask comes in because it really holds the
confidentiality of each individual
accessing our services but in some
instances those asks are directly
related to the workplace and so in that
way the recommendation would be for the
workplace all right thank you I'm I'm
not sure I phrase my question properly
what I'm looking for is whether or not
our EAP summarizes the aggregate overall
Health and Welfare of the of the the
body to provide overall situational
awareness of course individual privacy
is maintained but if there are some
general Workforce trends that are of
Interest is that something that is
separately called out and
reported we're moving to a data
management system that's just been
approved and that's going to allow us to
see in a larger way Trends impacting the
overall uh functioning in in departments
for now the way those requests have been
handled is on a case-by Case basis a
department by Department basis all right
uh are there are there any questions
representative Mooney thank you and
thank you for being here today
so in the methodology of the fiscal note
it mentions per person cost Etc does
this bill mean that it's entering a
scenario whereby there's a per person
cost for all 424 legislators even though
maybe 50 would use the service is that
how I'm reading this that is correct the
cost allocation formula the the number
is low per per per
person taking into account that fact
that not all 400 124 would likely
utilize it but I would also add that
that also um brings into the ability of
each legislator if if it were to pass
members of the household would also be
able to access the
resource okay that was really a great
detail because that had eluded me that
family members are eligible to use the
EAP as well if the benefit is provided
okay a question
yes uh thank you for coming and thanks
for taking my question um so the the 38
if if nobody used it would we pay
zero or or we pay a fixed amount per
person regardless of whether so that's
what you were saying there okay um uh do
you take into account that that you know
a lot of legislator have uh EAP programs
through their primary employment outside
of the legislature and is that something
that we should take into account in
budgeting this
program my stance on that question is
that I you know I want to be able to
provide resources to folks who are in
need of resources and I think that the
cost allocation formula speaks to kind
of the financial commitment I would
never stare anybody away from resources
they may already have but I also know
that we have a robust resource program
for state employees and folks who
contract and their family members
followup yeah so is is this rate the
same as for full-time employees of the
company of of of the state I mean yes
thank
you is is there another amendment that
you know of floating around on this I I
I I'm I'm curious if we have a couple
other Provisions uh one can a legislator
opt out so that they aren't included in
the in the aggregate cost to the
speaker's office and is there a way to
get the legislature legislator to
contribute to their own benefit much
like they do on the dental program is
there an amendment floating around that
I just don't know about um chairman
Edwards there was a discussion when the
bill was before the policy Committee in
legislative Administration it didn't
actually materialize in an amendment but
what they did clarify from their
discussions were to uh uh suggest an
amendment to include household members
so that it actually would be in the
language of the bill itself was one of
the provisions and another issue that
they had discussed was to identify
specifically that legislators were not
employees for purposes or to be
construed as employees for purposes of
this this act there was a conversation
in front of the with the policy
committee regarding exactly what you're
you're discussing which is the current
um provision for a dental benefit which
a legislator can on their own uh seek
and pay out of pocket for for those
benefits um given the current model that
we have for the employee assistance
program which is based upon the total
number of employees from a specific um
um state agency um that participates in
it that if we went to a different type
of model like a u u individual pay model
it would be uh it would lack parity with
the other Provisions that we already
have out there uh and it could run
contrary contrary to the funding
necessary to actually achieve the good
works they do at the EAP if you change
the funding model from that which has
already been in place for many many
years uh as it relates to our um
memorandum of agreements and with um
various state agencies I was going to
ask Mr Lawless if he thinks he could
condense it down to less words but I
think that that's hopefully as is um a
response to your your ultimate question
so summary is there's not an amendment
that came from all those discussions but
there were a lot of discussions in that
area and and and because we're on the
I'm going to come to you in second uh do
we have an an amendment on the timeline
that I had asked for yes can we go ahead
and hand that out and make sure people
are aware of it and then U I'll I'll I I
saw representative hle first and then
I'll go to representative
wer thank you Mr Williams for the
discussion The Current Dental employment
benefit that is available to the
legislature and in the past when I was a
rep I took advantage of that we paid for
that a benefit out of
pocket and my understanding of Cobra
laws allowed for that to continue as
well one does this if this benefit is
created and an employee leaves right A
legislature chooses not to file to run
for reelection or chooses to write or
does not win an elected seat
what happens is this now part of
Cobra I don't think Cobra is applicable
to what you do is it because you're not
Insurance we're not in insurance so
we're we're cobbling together a response
to that um so because it's not an
insurance product it doesn't fall under
Cobra uh it is a obviously a benefit
that is provided to State Employees but
it doesn't fall under the category of
insurance follow so if an employee left
today right a non-legislative employee
left today this Ben benefit would stop
upon their
departure the short answer is yes one of
the issues that was discussed at the
policy committee level was to insert in
front of the word members of the general
court uh the word current so it' be very
clear that we were talking about current
members and not either past members or
ones who might have resigned or moved
out of their particular district and had
to resign design uh so the suggestion
was to add to word current to make that
very clear good good question R thank
you
second so if if this is a benefit that
is available to all
400 some members are taking advantage
some members are
not is that is that Equitable to all
members of the
house and uh chairman Edwards
I like to respond to that go ahead so um
in terms of the numbers it it's actually
not just 400 uh for the representative
also the other 24 other bodies so
include also state
senators and and also uh members of
their their household um so the current
model that we have working with the
other state agencies is based upon an
understanding that the state agency
themselves pay for a proportion of those
costs for the services that Mr Lawless
and his employ employ assistance program
uh provide uh in terms of mechanics uh
50% is paid for by the department to
support his program which is budgeted
through this Division and then the other
50% is uh from the other agencies
transfers that we receive based upon
those um memorandum of agreements that
have been entered into individually in
terms of the equity uh uh the the way
that the EAP Works employee assistant
program it's available to all employees
uh life circumstances randomly happen to
folks whether it could be uh substance
use
um matters if it's um uh issues
involving uh better management of money
uh debtor creditor creditor um
Behavioral Health uh also um uh just all
Healthcare uh including Behavioral
Health uh that uh we would make sure
that they would be um served and the
fact that somebody wouldn't Avail
themselves of that uh I I would not
think that that would necessarily be a
an equity um argument it would just be a
personal choice or or not wanting to
engage or not having to engage but most
people do have life's struggles at some
point in time um Mr Al did you also have
a response at all to
that no other than just to add that the
the resources and the support I I
appreciate you bringing in the medical
piece because the the challenges that
can impact any individual state employee
family member I mean we we hear about it
we see it every day anything that can
impact one person is also available to
any one of us and so I think to that
point just knowing that there are
resources available um you know in terms
of that return on investment there's
there's a lot of evidence around the the
benefit of eaps and when you bring it
into the family the family realm I think
that's just another added layer around
what we all can carry when either we are
struggling with something or somebody
that's close to us is struggling L thank
you uh representative
wer here for many years we've we've been
strong on the point that we are not
employees in the legislature we are
elected by people we are not appointed
by anybody within government we can't be
fired by anyone within government we're
fired by the people who elected us so to
try to get into employee benefits I'm
opposed and I think that's why it
probably was defeated in the committee
um as you say we've been able to get
into some programs where we pay for them
and some people have got into the health
insurance but
that's kind of a privilege that's been
added
and you pay for it yourself so this I
see the model should be repeated the
same way here rather than having
everybody paid for whether they want it
or not we're not employees I want it see
so we shouldn't be an employee
assistance programs thank you so you
don't have to answer that that's a
legislative policy issue that's outside
the Department's purview but rep uh
representative H thank you this question
is for you I'm looking at the amendment
this may yes this
um it looks like the date might be have
typ should should should I introduce my
Amendment before you ask me questions
about sure let's I'll let you introduce
your
Amendment okay so so Mr Ripple passed
out U my amendment to this bill um that
uh the effective date is not a typo it's
July 1
2034 two so that's basically 10 years
what what's the rationale the rationale
builds off of what representative wer
said is that this is a new benef this
is there are no questions for you in
here um so um it it it it it it builds
off the idea that as legislators we're
not signing up for a compensation and
benefits plan like an employee and this
is a new benefit and because it's a new
benefit uh I would want to um separate
from the current
vote though that population that would
actually benefit from the benefit that
we would be creating with this bill and
so I I I just arbitrarily said 10 years
because I don't know how many of us
think that we're going to stick around
for 10 years so that we can get access
to the employee assistance program we'd
have to be a little uh uh I'm not going
to say the word nuts maybe but uh go
ahead thank you for your explanation I
was going to ask whether that could have
been July 1st
2025 which is the beginning of a new
bium
financially I thought it was a typo
that's how I took it but at a minimum it
should be the beginning of the next
budget cycle so that no one that I
understand your logic and I I completely
support your logic no one who is a
direct beneficiary of of the program
would be voting on the program and
there's a there's a congressional level
Constitutional Amendment type thing as
well that talks to this that we should
not be voting on things that affect
directly affect us so at a minimum even
if there's a separate amendment I would
request that it not be any sooner than
July 1st
2025 so if we go down that road I I'm
I'm totally open to discussing what the
end date is I just want to make sure
that there's a clear boundary between
the people who are voting to self Eng
grandis their benefits package from the
ones that actually receive it and I I
wanted separated you say by budget year
I I rather than say budget cycle I would
say election cycle because the you know
the voters should determine whether or
not we should be getting this additional
benefit not ourselves we're in agreement
okay U representative tki thank you I
would just like to say that um I can
support the logic for
2025 since all of us don't know if we're
going to be here next year
um and I think that you know we don't
know who those 424 people are but I
believe that the program itself is
invaluable to those who find themselves
in a situation of having to um need that
and I think it could help in terms of
retention of quality legislators
allowing them to um maybe get you know a
referral somewhere um um just a
listening ear to help them show up and
do their work um support themselves in a
way that allows them to serve allows
them to show up and I at first also with
my colleague over there thought it was a
typo but I think that by adjusting it to
2025 we may be in a position that we
could satisfy um
everyone's needs to push it
out all right um yes so so I the other
concerns I had about this I he I he
heard everything you said everything he
said is reasonable the free market is
validated eaps as being uh a worthwhile
employee investment so so I don't I
don't have an argument on on on that
level my my my argument against this
bill is that uh it's a new benefit for
legislators and as representative wer
pointed out and as I've come to
understand it is is that uh we we have
assiduously held to the idea that uh the
compensation we get per the Constitution
is pretty much everything we get I mean
we get mileage that's not in the
Constitution I don't think but um but
adding benefits for
legislators is just a really bad
precedent I don't want to break glass on
that I don't I don't want to do that and
then the fact that this is the first
cost free benefit that would go to
legislators we can sign up for the
dental program we can sign up for the
medical program but this would be at no
cost to a legislator and I I that's
another precedent that I would want to
avoid um the fact that this program
doesn't have an opt out procedure built
into it uh and that it's including
family members and so there's a kind of
a redundancy here because some people
have full-time benefits I think
representative Stringham alluded to that
you know so there's kind of a double
dipping or double benefit component to
this so so those are reasons that I have
a problem with this bill I just wanted
to get that out there and go ahead go
ahead well I'll say first off I don't
have a benefit since um I am not don't
have a full-time employer but I'm just
curious when you were talking about we
don't have a a benefit like that the
first thing that popped into my head was
the the um complex nurse the State House
nurse you know we we have that
opportunity to go and meet with the
nurse if we're having um I would say I'd
be welcome in there for a physical issue
but also um you know a mental health
issue I need um a little guidance on
something so I guess I would argue that
we do have a benefit like that related
to our well-being all right
I I think that's an excellent possible
example I I'd want to drill into it just
a little bit more uh it it was my
understanding that the the nurse on site
is really here for emergency care in
case somebody the day of session or the
day of committee needed some kind of
medical assistance I I I did not I have
not in four terms perceived the nurse as
somebody I could go to almost on a
clinical appointment basis to get you
know supplemental help other than
emergent care so that that's just a fact
thing that I I don't know do you do you
know my first term I had two different
surgeries and so I connected with her
often on my well-being and my ability to
serve and um getting a a better parking
spot getting some um over-the-counter
medications when I needed it when I was
in committee different things like that
and I I just you know I see that as a
benefit of working in the building and I
guess I'm just using that it's an
example that we already have
that did you have a question so you
haven't asked one yet so go ahead thank
you Mr chairman um my question is I I
had worked um when I was on that cuss
between being a contractor and an
employee and that line was very um
Nimble on the federal government's uh
definitions about when they decided that
you wanted to be considered an employee
even though you were you were were not
really acting as an employee I'm
concerned about what the cost would be
to the state if doing this would move us
towards a path of being deemed employees
and therefore subject to things like
minimum wage and other
benefits C could you elaborate on that
are you are you concerned that the um
the the the presence of one employee
like benefit could in trigger an
interpretation by a future court that we
are in fact employees and therefore
become uh un intentionally subject to
the minimum wage law um yes especially
if other benefits also
follow representative Stringham I I just
want to comment again from my own
experience a little bit differently that
you know we offer health insurance
employees all pay a portion of their
health insurance we offer retirement
employees contribute to their retirement
programs we offer Dental employees pay
portion of the dental we have an EAP
program employe employees don't pay
anything for that um um uh you know I I
I get your point of slippery slope I do
think an assistant program is about
having you know a body of people getting
work done that uh when they when they uh
need some kind of Psychosocial place
they have at least a place to start the
Ben the EAP program runs out pretty
quickly uh if somebody has you know a
major mental type of issue then it has
to go back into more traditional health
insurance or out of pocket payment so I
I don't uh you know while I appreciate
the uh um the enlightenment about uh
this kind of being an employee like
benefit I don't view it as an employee
benefit I view it this is something that
um um that you know the body that's
trying to get work done is doing so that
they have uh as capable a group ready to
move forward as possible especially
under these types of circumstances thank
you may I ask you a
question in an employee handbook in the
fields that you've been in where an
employee assistance program is offered
when the employee receives uh uh
something from HR saying here's your
compensation and and benefit package are
eaps listed as a benefit in the as part
of an overall benefit package
in my experience they have but I don't
i' I've only been in three different
corporations that had
eaps uh I appreciate the question I
don't remember if it's in the employee
manual or not
so Mr Williams so none of that was for
you but I'm just curious um as an
attorney um or do do you do you do you
feel like you're um in in the right area
to comment on representative Leon's
observation on the on employees that's a
special that's a special section of law
that you may not be familiar with to the
extent you're comfortable saying
something uh chairman Edwards thank you
I am here today in my capacity as the
legislative director I am active member
of New Hampshire bar my commentary is
the same observation that was raised by
represent Lon was also raised at the
policy committee before a legislative
Administration one of the uh potential
remedies to that is to put language like
this into the bill which would be
nothing in the section shall be
construed that members of the general
court or employees are otherwise deemed
anything but members of the legislative
branch that was one of the Alternatives
that was somewhat discussed before that
committee and I know that that's not
getting to the complete substance but
certainly if you need additional
information you have the wonderful
attorney Jim Santi who could be
available to you to address any other
further questions where where he does
represent the legislature do do either
of you have anything else to add u based
on the observing our conversation and
and do any legislators have any
questions to ask further representative
Mooney uh think about what you may want
to still
say thank you how many currently
full-time state employees have
access to the employee assistance
program yeah so the the the estimates
are over 10,000 of uh full-time state
employees when when this is initially
budgeted it's anticipated how many
positions may be filled and then you
know there's always kind of uh
transition every states with with
positions but it's over 10,000 at this
point and
part-time I don't have that number uh
and that may be represented in that
total number I apologize I I don't have
it uh separated that way thank you
fulltime I'm guessing is 35
hours most employees 37 37 and a half I
should say most but there are 40 hour
employees depending on uh some of the
institutions part time is approximately
20 or
so I'm I'm I'm not sure whatever okay I
guess my my question then becomes if
this bill were to pass legislators would
be for lack of a better phrase the least
working
class of individuals to access this
program considering some don't have
committee assignments off for the summer
campaigning in the fall and so on so
forth is that an accurate
statement what what I would say to that
is I know we provide services to
seasonal employees and and there's many
departments that contract us that have a
different kind of range of what hours
their employees may work so I wouldn't
be able to say more than that so so I
think you're bringing up an excellent
point we we are the the smallest part of
the part-time employee Force technically
and and so could you give us get to us a
copy of of the policy that says you know
part-time this is whether or not you're
eligible whether it's seasonal or
whatever I I I I just want to be able to
Benchmark what the legislature is
relative to the part-time employees that
receive this benefit we don't
distinguish between part-time and
full-time in terms of our service
delivery model if you are no no no no
not Service delivery but
eligibility anybody would be
eligible if if an employee is working
five hours a week I don't know that we
have any of those but they would be
eligible for the EAP program if they
were if they had paid based on that cost
allocation formula then they would be
eligible for the same
services
r r uh Mr
White good good afternoon members of the
committee uh Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with health and human
services so I just kind of want to level
set just to help address this question
so this coming August and every other
August during the agency budget phase we
work with EAP to develop their budget so
for the current fisal year $928,000
we also during that point in time we
work with the Department administrative
services to identify what are all of the
funded classified and unclassified
positions that currently exist um for
the current budget it was almost
11,000 um we take that we apply a ratio
and then we divy it up and so when you
look at our budget when we work with
division three a percentage of that
roughly half is other funds the money
coming from the other state agencies and
then the remaining amount is federal and
general funds for hhs's budget um so so
we do not budget down to the part-time
employee level when we're making these
decisions so if this bill were to pass
the 424 additional members would
basically be factored into that roughly
11,000 which would represent I don't
know like 4% something like that off the
back just back of the envelope math um
so so that would be that 17 that roughly
$177,000 annual impact where we would
assume we would receive s roughly
$177,000 from the legislature to pay for
that to provide those
Services okay so that was good that's
all money right it isn't specifically
eligibility but but I I I I think it's
safe to assume that part of the
eligibility answer is they have to be
hired and they can't be uh no longer an
employee they have to be actively
employed and as long as they were
employed enough to show up in one of
those
classification levels then there was
probably a cost allocation done and the
money has been taken care of and and the
implication is that they have
eligibility yes and and the budget is
based on total funded positions not
total filled positions funded okay okay
uh representative Leon U thank you Mr
chairman um it when seasonal employees
were mentioned I was curious as to
whether seasonal employees if they come
back every season are provided this
benefit when they're not working just as
legislators who are in the off seon and
not coming in do you know if those
seasonal employees that are hired every
year um receive this benefit when
they're not actually working for the
state and putting in any hours I don't
have that information in front of me I I
think that and a taking that question as
a case-by Case Model if somebody reached
out and said that they were an employee
a seasonal employee we wouldn't be
saying but are you currently working uh
we would still provide the same Services
if they reached
out
thank you represent
hle we covered the number of employees
that are eligible do you have any data
relative to the usage of this service
number of phone calls right by month
by however you'd have the
data so again I'll reference our data
management system because you know in
the in the close to 40 years that the
program has been in place a lot of our
data has been uh kind of paper and
pencil Excel and trying to really
identify what a what an what a client
contact constitutes is uh it covers a
lot of ground in certain ways and so
what I will say is looking at our most
most um research suggests that eaps
operate at about a 6% uh utilization we
are we exceed at least 10% and the
reason why I'm a bit vague with that is
because when we look at actual numbers
of clients served in terms of uh direct
meetings face Toof face or telephonic
opening a case and providing specific
resources um the the most recent
information I've seen is over 700
looking at the calendar year which is
actually an uptick related to uh impart
the events at New Hampshire hospital but
when we when we really kind of open that
up even further in terms of the data
management system providing us real
updates around Service delivery and
Trends one of the things that that
number doesn't take into account is the
is the fact that we do a number of
different groups we do orientations we
do trainings we do conflict resolutions
within agencies and so to uh to look at
what is counted as a case what is
counted as a client contact those
numbers exceed even the numbers that
I've uh greatly exceed those numbers
that I referenced is it possible for you
to get us that data just at some level
in some format
yes are are there other questions from
the legislators I I that that triggered
an interesting thought if you step into
help with conflict resolution we could
keep you pretty
busy well I thought of that earlier but
I didn't want to assume too much there
but we we certainly are available in way
all right so so what I'm what I'm going
to do with this is um I'm going to go
ahead and recess HB
1363 on the possibility that we can come
back uh the last thing we do today to uh
uh determine what we want to do with it
if we want to um execute late today or
if we want to uh carry it over to next
week we can talk about that after we
recess all right all right so um I'm
going to put uh HB
1363 uh into the recess
mode thank you and with that uh I'm
going to bring to uh forward word um
1282 Rel relative to the duration of
Child
Support is is there anyone here that's
meant to speak on
1282 any additional words we did hear it
last week but if there's anyone that
wanted another shot or another bite at
the Apple this is the time to do
it anyone in the
audience public comment kind
of if if you feel like you need more
space or more mics we got the mics at
the end of the table
but all uh go ahead and introd roduce
yourselves for the
record sure my name is David weers I'm
the information Services director for
the health and human services
department I'm Susan Bron I'm the chief
staff attorney for the office of child
support and good afternoon my name is
Lisa dekowski and I am the bureau chief
with the Bureau of Child Support
Services with the Department of Health
and Human
Services all right go ahead and tell us
what you want to tell us
okay last week uh you indicated a number
of questions surrounding the IT
solutions I just wanted to address those
today and and just so you know we did
that systemically we said all of these
bills before us have like an IT
component go take a look at the totality
coordinate the totality and come back to
us to tell us the implications on cost
and and and implementation timing I I
think that's what that was right that is
correct thank you I do have a handout
however it's not whole punched if you
want that handout oh
no my apologies for the lack of ho
punches um so the handout actually goes
through a number of bills as you
indicated chairman um in particular for
HB
1282 we looked at this solution and in
order to implement these changes we need
to amend the existing contract with our
vendor to support the child support
system that process takes about six
months to do amendments working with our
federal Partners as well as our state
procurement practices and then following
that six months we would need an
additional six months for implementation
of these changes so with that the
effective date would be that we could be
able to meet the um the requirements of
this bill would be a July 1st
2025 in which point we would be able to
go live with those changes to support
this this
bill in response to the question as to
whether or not we have the projects
related to this bill resourced and
prioritized in our project management
system assuming the bill passage the
department would submit it through our
pmo process and I identify the resources
needed to move this
forward what's what's your confidence
level you just said 6 months plus 6
months um is do do you need do you need
an extra cushion of time in there or are
you highly
confident we think we're okay we're
we're highly confident that we'd be able
to achieve these changes in that
timeline okay did you have a revised
cost estimate no the cost estimate
that's in this promote is the same okay
so it would just slide the spending
maybe okay um um are there any questions
about 1282 the only financial impact on
this was the it
implementation not I'm not seeing any so
um I'll give it another minute for
people to look at it representative tki
I just have a question and I apologize
that I wasn't here um last week and I
was I caught a little bit of it um these
this list of that you have here that you
reviewed and I apologize again if I this
has been stated um is the fiscal note on
this is it the changes that are going to
have to be done to the the technology
side um is it the same cost for all of
them in other words it's not an
individual cost on each bill it's you're
going to have a larger package to revise
your
software that is a good question in the
case of these systems they're individual
so each bill impacts different systems
within the department we have a little
over 200 application systems that we
support in the case of this bill it's um
the New England Child Support
Enforcement system that is impacted and
so other bills will impact impact other
systems so this is a individual Bill
cost okay could sorry follow up um was
just comparing this one
to now I got to find the right one and
it had an identical fiscal note in terms
of the numbers so I was wondering if it
was that amount to revise the system
for
both but that's okay maybe I was looking
at the wrong thing but you answered my
question um I I I think that was a good
observation there there were uh as Mr
weer said most of these bills are
touching different it systems but there
were two bills that were touching the
same system this particular system and I
think the cost estimates were the same
but but but and but we should keep them
independent as each bill tries to go
through the system I just wanted to make
sure that the department had had an
opportunity to take a look at the whole
the whole impact if they had to do all
of the it
systems because the the their scarcest
resources really isn't the money it's
making sure that they have the trained
project management people and the the
team ready to go so
so good good good good question
uh I I um I don't have any more
questions on 1282 does anyone have
questions on
1282 representative Mooney thank you Mr
chair we did discuss amending the
effective
date what we did last time discuss
amending the effective
date so so yes is there a question there
there I don't think I think if we if we
decide we want to go forward it probably
needs an amendment
right correct I didn't know if you were
gearing up to make a move right now but
I I'd like to get through the three
child support ones and then and then
maybe loop back around to see if we have
uh thoughts on uh exec the the each bill
because we have to probably exec each
bill
um but I want to go through the three
just to make sure we know where we're
at any other
questions okay so do you want to just
drop down to um 1595 which I think is
the other uh one operating on the same
it
system 15595 I think if I'm
wrong I could be wrong
um 1595 is on the same Child Support
Enforcement system we we call it Nexus
for short um so if you ever hear the
acronym Nexus it it does down for New
England Child Support Enforcement system
1595 in 1564 have the exact same um
fiscal impact into the system and
depending on if they both move forward
um we would have some conflicts however
if they were merged together we would
have a single cost of the of the
$290,000 and when it comes to effective
date it follows the same challenges that
we have with the previous Bill where we
would need to amend the existing
contract for services to accommodate
those changes which would have a ability
for the Department to implement with an
effective date of July 1st
2025 um to address the same question of
the previous Bill we do have confidence
that if we had the two bills move
forward we would have the resources to
be able to move both Solutions
forward all right
um for the uh go go ahead representative
walner my my question is really for
child enforcement not for the
technical so my my my question is I just
heard the word merge them together and
I'm wondering are they compatible can
they be merged together if you merge
them
together what does that mean then
because that seems like again that seems
like a policy issue of merging them
together thank you for your question it
definitely a policy issue I think there
are parts of them that can be merge
together um but then other parts that
definitely
conflict so we if conflict or are just
um they're not aligned with each other
do they actually conflict and fight each
other or or or do they match up except
where they don't no I would say that
they they conflict in that there are
certain
circumstances described circumstances
for child support that are different in
one building in the
other thank thank thanks for that and
and so on 1595 has an amendment uh the
bigford amendment uh
014 um uh representative Bickford would
would you sit over here and grab a mic
over on the on the
side no you don't have to get up
ma'am if you want to get more notes to
shoot at us that's okay
okay have have you I'm I'm sorry I'm so
bad with names ma'am uh you're have you
seen representative Bickford's
[Music]
Amendment uh one14 is How It
Ends and so because you pointed out a
potential
conflict uh I wanted I I I will come
back to you after you've had a chance to
think about it and see if that in your
mind resolves the potential conflicts
that we might have between these two
bills all right uh representative
bigford what what would you like to tell
us about your Amendment
sir what what the amendment does is pick
up the uh self support
res
closer what it does is picks up the self
support Reserve from
1564 and it puts in a domestic violence
uh CL clause in there that 1564 also has
but what we need to do is decide on
which child support formula we're going
to go with the one 1595 has a formula
that's recommended by years of study
we've spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars on these studies that I pointed
out to you the last time which has a
what they call a 1.5 multiplier in it uh
the one in 1564 is a simple uh cross
credit and it only works when you have
the exact same income and the exact same
parenting time after
that it it will you'll find the um the
lower earner will start moving away from
even having an even with the other party
so it it does damage the uh lower earner
the one the cross it's called cross
credit and it's just it's a simple thing
um but it's not recommended by all the
studies that we
have the uh the one
we so so sticking on the amendment it
it's lines 17 through 20 what are the
what was the purpose for this what are
we trying to do with with that with
those lines well you had spoke about
having one bill going with follow one
bill and this would do it but you would
not be going far with 1564 anymore okay
so this would allow 1595 to to carry the
load
exactly okay does does the department
concur with that
that I would I would say that it I mean
it definitely includes things from 1564
that it did not before
um I'm loathed to say it completely
deals with it with the prime sponsor in
the room I mean she might have a
different she might have a different
opinion but
uh all right so so we don't we we can
bring you back on this we can we can
either recess it for later today or if
you think you guys need some time to to
continue to resolve it we're going to
have another work session next week
where I hope it uh concludes in an exec
session so so any sort of U disputes
between the two uh we should be prepared
to handle
uh what I want to I want to ask the
chair did you want to comment on either
of these representative
kab it was that a no you do
not if you may
sure
okay good morning for the record I'm
kitlyn cab thank you for hearing me so
basically the special committee on the
Family Court heard a lot of testimony
from from parents that there's long been
a child support issue in New Hampshire
and I looked back and we've had over a
dozen bills come through and every year
we'll get something through the house
and it gets to the Senate and it gets
ited so knowing that parents really
needed something I brought together all
the stakeholders over the summer we had
New Hampshire Association of Justice we
had New Hampshire legal aids several
Family Court attorneys mediators we got
everybody together to come up with
something that would work we also ran
this by a few of the judges just to make
sure that we're putting in something
where we're not going to you know break
the 80% that are agreeing that are going
through mediation but in in trying to
correct it for the 20% who aren't
agreeing and this was the bill that we
came up with and it and it fix it fixes
three of the the big issues that have
kind of come out which one of them was
increasing the self-support reserve from
115% to
130% and then it allows for the parties
to um share the cost of child care
Healthcare and extracurricular
activities that are agreed upon and then
it allows for some rebuttable
presumptions of deviations to the child
support calculator based on shared
parenting time and it was really one of
the big sticking points and if if you
kind of look back it this bill came out
of committee 13 to0 verse 1595 came out
of committee 7 to6 um we couldn't get
agreement on changing a whole calculator
solely just based on parenting time
because then you were going to have
parents arguing hour for hour about how
much time they're spending with each
kiddo and so that was kind of one of the
big sticking points
from New Hampshire legal aid and the
domestic violence Coalition they wanted
it to truly be in the best interest of
the child and so this was the Compromise
that we came up with and I really think
you
know it has uh I think it'll be good for
for the for the families in the state of
New
Hampshire all right so when you say this
is the compromise 1564 is the compromise
1564 is the compromise correct and and
so am I hearing you right there that
your
recommendation from your committee from
from policy perspective is that we ought
to be passing 1564 and and not either
1282 or 1595 so 12 1282 deals with
something entirely different it's okay
to pass 1282 is is completely different
okay so the so the the conflict is
between 64 and 95 correct okay all right
um representative Wallner you had a
question well I guess my question is now
to to both but I was wondering uh when
representative Bickford was here and he
has an amendment is this an amendment
that the children and family law
committee has seen and
support or is this an amendment from the
sponsor
no no to
which well the no it does well I don't
know about support because they never
they've seen it in six it's just taking
stuff out of 1564 and putting this so I
guess yes the answer is yes it has seen
it and I would have to say yes it does
approve what's in the
amendment okay and do the members of or
at least a portion of the members of the
children and family law committee know
that you're bringing forth this
amendment to finance because it's a
policy and I am no concern no we we have
not met since I came here last okay
thank you and I heard about having one
one bill so this this uh we'll achieve a
one bill thing I mean the the the
problem is she bring fall one bill with
a uh calculator or formula in it and I
challenge that and say that those people
did not utilize this which we paid
$114,000 to tell us what to give us a
direction to go in and not only did this
one do it we paid
$140,000 for this one four years before
that in the 19 and it says the same
thing and then the family law task force
in 2004 told us to do that and gave us
recommendations same thing in
2009 I mean it just goes back and back
for over 20 years telling us that this
formula that I'm bringing forward to you
is the one we should be uh
adopting I I represent tki thank you um
I would like to just direct a question
to the uh experts here at the center of
the table if I may um when I Was
preparing for today I did have a couple
conversations with members of children
and family law to try to understand
since we are not the policy committee on
this and someone said very simply to me
that 1264 uh sorry
1564 is um they described it as the
collaborative um you know all the
parties coming together to work on it
and said that it's a small step um it's
a the changes are more um moderate um
but there was a lot of agreement about
it whereas they said
1595 was like overturning the Apple card
it was like a huge 180 from where um the
process is now would that be a correct
assessment I I I would say you want me
to answer that no I was asking
the I don't know know if DHHS wants to
answer your question as worded do you
want to reward your question
which I'm trying to understand and which
one is a more
significant change to current um
practice and which one might be a um a
step um in trying to fix the problems we
have which one and one it seems to me
from what I'm hearing one is a very
large shift from where we are now and
one is a little bit more of a moderate
step
I would say that that 1564 is definitely
uh a simpler
change it's leaving in place most of
what we do now and only changes it in
certain shared
parenting
circumstances but it doesn't give any
guidance in
other circumstances whereas
1595 deals with all the circumstances
that answers my question so so so I
think for the record I I should have um
probably gone ahead and open 1282
1564 and 1595 we kind of talked about
them all uh which is which is good we
are a work session so we're working uh
representative Hull thank you Mr chair
um in my pile of handouts was a document
comparing some of these with specific
information in various C colums but
unfortunately no one told me who turned
that in do we know does anybody remember
this document here who submitted that as
testimony that young lady over there
came from the National Parents org thank
you you had your hand up first was that
the same
answer you you present you prepared the
document okay thank
you would I'd like to if I may answer
question also for go ahead
representative delki um yes they're
absolutely right this is a much uh 1595
is a much more
comprehensive uh bill that covers uh
child support um one of the other
problems with 1564 is it's it's very
likely to drive the deviations up and
the reason for these reports that we are
required
to have is to find out where the
deviations are and if we if I a get too
high which they're very high
now um when you don't when the
guidelines doesn't work anymore for you
say you do a shared parenting situation
uh the guidelines we have now is just
for excuse me for a a one parent
situation so like I think 41 states have
changed in recognizing shared parenting
and 21 states I think are doing this
style it's in the report and uh we have
this this is very closely aligned with
California and
Oregon um now I forget what I was say oh
deviation deviation is yes when they
when the guidelines just don't work for
it they try to come up with something
different the uh Supreme Court came down
on the judges and said you can't be
doing that uh any these cross credits
anymore and so that's why we're here to
come up with a formula like I say there
are formulas out there that are in the
in the system and uh this is a very
popular one right
here uh does that help uh I I'll bet
attorney bristen can answer it better
than I
can I I think you were the primary
recipient of that answer representative
tersi but if if our deviations get too
high they can come back as I understand
and tell us you're going to have to make
some changes so if we're just doing very
uh simplistic changes and they're going
to be dependent upon the deviations
there a good chance they'll come back
and say you're out of compliance
may I respond to
that so in speaking with several of the
judges there would be no issue with 1564
they'd be able to do it just fine I
think you know one of the big concerns
that came out is that we are not
California or Oregon we do not have the
types of uh welfare programs that those
states have to support like um daycare
subsidies and and various subsidies that
those other states have and so there is
concerns when you're reducing just
across the board making such a big
change like this that families aren't
going to be able to
afford the needs of their children and
we have to remember that the children
are the ultimate piece here that we need
to focus on and so that's why there was
a lot of push back and that's why each
time it gets over to the other side of
the wall it's been killed um we need to
come up with kind of a more moderate
approach to it and then if there's more
that needs to be done then we work at it
a little bit more but to go from you
know one way to completely flipping it
around it does cause for some
concern but in terms of the deviations
it would it would be right now they're
not allowed to deviate because that
that's what the statue
says but this would be allowing them to
deviate so it would fix the problem and
there wouldn't be a problem with
it are there any other comments from the
floor anyone in the audience would you
like to come up you we haven't heard
from you yet could you could I give you
a couple seconds on deviations y every
time you do a child support order at
court you're required to do what's
called a child support guidelines
worksheet which fills out basic facts of
the case and leads ultimately to the
math the calculation of what the child
support is supposed to
be that number is the guidelines
worksheet is provided to the court and
is eventually will be attached to
file the so the court knows what that
number is if the court chooses to pick a
different number for whatever reason
that's a
deviation and those are the type of
things that are that are
tracked that that was helpful to me
thank
you do you want to introduce yourself
for the record and and tell us what you
want to say uh sure my name is Rebecca
Hutchins um I'm a mom of two from Dover
um I was part of the working group for
1595 um we've spent a long time really
reviewing the research and it's um I
understand that we and you may have
gotten my testimony from yesterday um I
also sent in this chart that kind of
walks through each of the major areas I
um I hear what Caitlyn uh representative
cab excuse me is saying and
and the issue is that the working group
from 1564 did not include parents it
included a lot of litigators who go to
court and try this all the time I've
been back and forth to court in The Last
5 Years to change my child support order
six times because we don't have a tool
that works for families that have shared
parenting we continue to fight because
it
costs the same amount of money in two
houses it costs more than what the child
support calculator that we currently
have shows so all of the funds I pay my
ex I still also pay all of the
extras I still care for my kids half of
the time when we start talking about
social services and what needs to happen
because people are going to be getting
less money what about the families that
have been paying overpaying for over 20
years when this research has been out
telling us that we need to change
this there's no aers that I will
receive none of that will get
rectified and all it does is cause more
fighting between
families we were not included in 1564 I
have reached out to the
nhla I've reached out to the New
Hampshire Association for
justice my calls were not I did speak
with Mary Krueger in in depth about the
issues the the domestic violence issue
that we've spoken of um
in conversation it seems that there are
only four cases that it would actually
affect currently with the
nhla there's been conversations about
course of control with financial
situations I say it works both
ways the obligor is not the
abuser sure I don't I don't want to I
cause you to end prematurely I wish that
I could convince you that so so let's
back up sure so it it's your testimony
that you think um parental involvement
should cause us to want to pass1
1595 and the lack of Parental
involvement does that affect your
position on
1564 1564 only helps a very narrow group
of people that already agree to share
all costs 5050 it's the only group that
they're working with okay I just I just
wanted to get your position so yes or no
to 1564 it seems to help some people if
if I'm hearing you right
it
1564 and
1595 can be combined to create a tool if
1564 is to pass as is there's a whole
middle section section
five that would cause more deviations
which is absolutely against the review
MH and cause more conflict for families
trying to navigate this myself included
okay thank thank you and your last name
is Hutchin or Huggin Hutchin Hutchin are
there any questions from the panel for
Miss Hutchins oh I
do question for the chair can we get a
pink
card I I don't know that our work
sessions use pink cards Mr Ripple do we
do that just so we have contact
information I I think we want to know
how to get hold of you so so if you
could give us your contact information
happy too all right all right but but
technically we don't use pink cards for
our work sessions do we you don't need
them for work sessions
no I I think the biggest thing that I
just want to say is that if both of
these pass uh which one do you get more
bang for your
buck right they cost the same amount of
money one helps a tiny group and the
other helps
everyone including the family court
which is already 95
95 helps everyone the the family courts
already having trouble families are
already getting uh different rulings
based on whichever judge you
get this doesn't help 95 will will solve
that represent question of the
chair so This falls in division three
because it's in the domain of families
and Healthcare and right kind of our
jurisdiction but there's a large element
of this that division one was
considering relative to judges and that
I do have a question and I'm not sure
who the right person to ask this of
whether it's our other division or
whether it's someone from the judicial
branch does either one of these have a
lower impact meaning less need for more
judges my current understanding is we
are 177 judges short in New Hampshire as
of
now so you're going to have to refresh
my memory because I I I don't think
there the fiscal note on these three
bills actually put a dollar next to the
impact on the Judiciary I don't think it
does but I do think there is an element
of how we change
policy relative to the impact on the
amount of time in the courtroom and
because of that and knowing that we have
this gaping hole of number of Judges if
one of those actually reduces is the
workload that's advantageous to the
state and that's the question I'm trying
to get
to okay so I can wrap my head around
that one uh be just between 64 and um
95 which one feels to you representative
katab as having
um a a benefit to the workload
management of the Judiciary do they are
they both equivalent on on judicial
workload or or
different thank you for the question so
I'm not sure that there would
necessarily be much of a Judicial impact
although I will say
that the mediators did feel like 1564
would help some more parents to be able
to come to agreement that are currently
in conflict and keep them out of going
to court so about 80% of the parties
tend to settle outside of court and 20%
of
them are more higher conflict and need
to get decided in court so they felt
like they'd be able to get some more
parties to actually agree they were
concerned with adding the element of
arguing over the number of days with
each party with 1595 that it was going
to create more
conflict in representative Bickford it
looks like you have a different opinion
yes I do in fact if when I had read
the
$114,000 thing it says it will be less
conflict in there and uh you just go to
the table they'll have a table and
they'll have a a graph there and that
says well this much time this kind of
income and bang There It
Is and she she probably knows more about
it than I do I I I I think I want to
start wrapping this up are are there
other questions uh from the legislators
from the
panel any last words of wisdom from
people who come
forward all right so
um I'm going to go ahead and recess
these three bills and representative
walner
uh I want to be able to talk to you
during the course of the afternoon about
whether or not we could you think we
ready to exec any of
these okay all right well thank you very
much uh that that closes uh those three
bills uh I would like to and those three
bills are 1282 1564 15
1995 I want to open uh
1669 oh representative Lehman you're
here now I didn't see you come in um
okay because you're here um I'm going to
go ahead and open uh
1573 now the reason we're going to 1573
next is because uh the fiscal node has a
fairly dramatic impact on the judicial
branch and division one handles the
Judiciary so I wanted to uh make sure
that um their point of view is
integrated in in in what we know and
what we
think
um so going to
1573 Okay so
1573 did we did we have the Pearson
Amendment before us last week
0980 we did we
did
okay certainly a lot of room I go go
ahead thank you Mr chair yes that
amendment was introduced and discussed
last week though I feel uh there's a lot
of room for further discussion on that
as it wasn't entirely described or
really uh combed through as adequately
as I think it could have
been all right uh oh go ahead
representer walner well I I just wanted
to remind you that this is the one we
have the subcommittee on right and I
think um
I've called the subcommittee for
Wednesday morning at 10: I've reached
out to both the department and to the
child Advocates office but also today we
also contacted um the judicial
Branch about um having a representative
there on Wednesday to talk about the uh
fiscal note that that's in the bill for
the judicial branch okay so uh thank
thank you thank you for the trigger
there I I I do want to say for the for
the public and those that are here that
1573 um represents uh the legislator's
attempt to resolve a fairly significant
problem that we had without placing uh
juveniles out of state because we didn't
have the capacity for them and that um
it came in with a a pretty hefty initial
cost estimate uh we've asked the
department and and other stakeholders uh
to include OCA to to go back to the
drawing board to really
prioritize uh where where we're getting
value where we're confident that we're
we're improving the system reducing the
risk to our kids and and but and doing
it in a more efficient and less
expensive way because there's enough
moving Parts here uh We've set up in the
division a um subcommittee that
representative walner has volunteered to
head up of of three people uh
representative priest herself and myself
she's been working with the Department
the department has been working hard uh
trying to go around all the stakeholders
to figure out you know what do we really
need to do and um and so representative
walner has us on track to have a
subcommittee meeting on Wednesday
morning and and we're going to see how
much we've learned since last week and
it it feels in the informal progress
reports I've been getting from Ms Morris
and you can come on and and take a seat
because I want to ask you where we're at
my my
general perception is that the
department has been working hard and
successfully at coming up with some
mutual accommodations of concerns at
maybe a lower cost to the state so that
that's my introduction for you you you
you you can you can refute that right
away if you
want no um I would say that we've been
working closely with the OA because we
do agree with the general premise of the
bill we agree with the the desire to
increase our scope and in create a more
robust program we just want to make sure
we can do it efficiently and effectively
uh within the financial constraints so
for the record I do you have uh M
Morris's information okay go ahead oh
sorry um so yes we are working with them
we have shared with them any uh changes
we would recommend and then we're going
to try to work on some financials for
you on Wednesday as
well so because you're you're changing
the overall recommendation of what we do
with this bill is it it is it's the case
then that the fiscal note still needs to
be updated to catch up with where you
guys are aiming to be on Wednesday
correct okay so we don't have we don't
have new fiscal or a new fiscal note
today for that we really should consider
very hard Mr Ripley you want to say
something you don't have a new fiscal
note the only thing I have is a
spreadsheet provided by the department
but again not in response to the
amendment discussed last week but rather
in response to the bill as amended by
the
house all right so so to the panel I I
would suggest uh or I'll tell you what
I'm going to do and you can do what you
want I'm I'm not really even going to
look at it because I want to wait until
um you know the paint has kind of dried
on the new look to the bill and and then
consider the adequacy of that new
proposal and then we can worry about the
money after that so so so I think next
week a week from now we'll bring 1573
back and and really be able to bring it
back to the whole division three to
figure out what we want to do so um do
would you mind just giving us like the
three or four major highlights of the
trend that you're going from what
1573 represented when it came to
division three and we're we're it you
think it may be trending I don't I don't
want you get out on a branch though um I
can tell you one major change will be
the certification process the
recommendation in 1573 as it passed the
house was for visits per year we are
saying uh we are recommending at least
two and it will say at a minimum too one
will be the
annual timely you know scheduled appoint
uh certification and then the second one
will be
unannounced so a spot check okay and
then because we have division one here I
I I I have to specifically ask have you
um had anyone from the Judiciary take a
look at the new proposal is there a new
proposal for when they're supposed to
get engaged is there any impact on the
initial fiscal note that was dealing
dealing with judicial I don't believe
there are any major changes to that
portion um that would remain the same
but that is something I defer to the OCA
on the
OCA come on up okay and you to that
better than I can and and for those who
are curious why I I point that
out um on the fiscal note uh the fiscal
note suggests that the judicial branch
requires nine new positions and that's a
bunch of new positions and I know over
the past year or two or three uh
division one's been funding a growth in
the judicial branch and
um representative leechman if if you'd
like it it would be perfectly great if
you joined us at the at the table so
that you feel comfortable asking any
questions
well if you have no I'm just saying if
you have questions I'd like you to be
able to use a mic
um all right so so would you introduce
yourself again and and and say something
that causes representative Lehman to
have
questions see what I can do uh attorney
Lisa masio I am the associate child
advocate for the State of New Hampshire
um I think one point of clarification in
the new amendment that is coming is that
prior amendment was not intended to be a
replace
all Amendment it was just intended to
make some some small tweaks um so
essentially that section around the
Judiciary would be the same as what was
passed by the house at the end of
February we have looped in Erin krian
who is the um judicial legislative LS on
I think the conversations we'd like to
have with her and I I do hope that she
is coming Wednesday morning is just
around the data and the numbers of kids
that this
um new Provisions around hearings would
touch that it's a pretty small
percentage of the total number of
children in placement um so hopefully we
would be able to have a more robust
conversation about those costs when we
talking very specific data number of
kids where they are under which purview
they're placed whether it's 169b C D or
a voluntary placement which doesn't
involve the
court so this may be a little bit of a
jump B question um I know the department
has spent a lot of time rethinking how
we can um make the the kind of the
clinical oversight role more efficient
has any effort been done to take a look
at streamlining or improving the
obligations or the reducing the
obligations on the J
Judiciary and this could be kind of a
yes or no
first has there there been an effort to
take a look at the judicial workload to
see if there's a way to redo the
workload so that they need fewer
people not not between the two of us no
but that's why we're hoping to Loop in
Aaron krian to to have some of those
conversations okay so so um
representative Hall do you have comment
I do thank
you during the public hearing on this
there was a discussion about changing
the Paradigm from routinely forcing the
judicial branch to
review I don't remember whether it was
every 30 or 60 I think I heard both days
what was going on to a paradigm where it
was a strategy of elevation If the child
care the case worker or somebody else
triggered an event the judicial branch
had a certain time to respond was that
language even looked into since we last
were
here we certainly did discussed that I
think the purpose of this bill overall
as well as the amendment is both
preventive in nature was also a response
to the Judiciary kind of saying they
felt they weren't getting enough
information as well as long term at
least from the office of child advocate
standpoint in line with director feser's
uh goal to to get kids out of
residential care so the purpose of the
increased judicial oversight of that
small subset of children was really to
help move them more quickly out of
Residential Care both helping the child
and reducing the cost to the state for
paying for that so it didn't really
align with an idea of just waiting till
there's a problem and elevating it
because the idea is to get the kid out
of Residential Care More
swiftly followup so I understand that
and I I can see why triggering the judge
and getting the judicial branch to
review this but by no means are they
going to be experts in the world of of
child care of treatment right this this
this that expertise is in the office of
child advocate is in DCF right is the
case workers are going to have far more
expertise about this than the judicial
branch so having the independent review
of the judicial branch I don't know that
gets that gets us to that solution I do
think that if there is a problem and we
need to make we need a court order to
address that quickly that that that
trigger mechanism has real value if if I
believe we heard testimony about someone
being restrained
inappropriately if that's going on
having a means to elevate that quickly
even through some sort of expar court
order system service would be beneficial
and I don't know that the amendment
that's been proposed addresses
that I appreciate the question this
amendment does not address that um that
mechanism already exists um I've
practiced both as a parent attorney and
as a dcyf attorney in the system a
motion can be filed at any time by any
of the parties in order to get judicial
oversight if there is an urgent issue I
think some of the question you're asking
is actually addressed in HB 585 which
was a retain bill that the house passed
in January and is reflected also in
s463 which gives attorneys to children
in residential placement which would be
frankly the person who would file that
escape Clause um urgent
motion what were those two build numbers
s SP 463 and HB 585 it was retained last
session and was passed by the house on
January 3rd whenever you guys had that
first floor session thank
you question for you represent w W ER
did did you mention to me that we had
somebody here from the judicial branch
that was going to talk today or or did I
make that up or did somebody else tell
me well I think I said that we had
reached out to someone from the judicial
branch to join us on Wednesday now
whether that person I don't I don't know
the person when I see them so if uh
they're here they might be but we did
let them know that on Wednesday will be
meeting and I'm hoping that she can be
there at that point oh thanks for the
reminder okay so this this is what I had
in my head and I'm I'm wondering if I
need to re-evaluate this I what I was
hoping we would be able to do Wednesday
is to really understand what the the the
final Amendment ought to look like to
1573 go ahead and get that over to OS so
that we could consider it
Monday I'm wondering if we've done
enough um homework on looking at the
judicial obligations to to include them
in the one more Amendment or if we still
have sort of a separate track that ought
to be worked what what are your thoughts
on
that well neither today or the day that
we had the public hearing on this do
have we heard from the Judiciary so I
think I would want to wait hear from
them before I started making any sort of
changes or modifying anything right so
so so right now I'm just thinking about
my timeline which was that we ought to
be done with the homework Wednesday
morning but we really haven't even
opened the the can of worms yet on
looking at a j on the Judiciary so I
don't think it's reasonable Wednesday
morning to have a potential uh
re-engineering of the J judicial
obligations and time for OS to write an
amendment for Monday that's that's sort
of where I'm at does that sound rational
that my timeline is we need to readjust
my timeline I think we probably need to
readjust the timeline all
right okay so um representative leechman
uh would you like to I would like to
invite member of division one to to come
join representative wall walner
subcommittee Wednesday morning because
because we're we're very good at at at
at working with DHHS to relook this
stuff but you know if there's if there's
something in here that division one
needs reworking because of the financial
impact then we I think we need to get
you engaged with
us
all right so so for the folks at home uh
division one chairman Peter Lehman said
that uh they're busy Wednesday morning
but they're going to try to have
representation at the
subcommittee um all right so thank you
for what you guys are doing do do you
have any final words now that we've
we've kicked over some rocks and we're
going to we're going to work harder on
on Wednesday morning try to come up with
something and see see how far we can go
got anything else nope I think we're
we're good on this end thank you okay uh
anyone in the
audience all right so I'm going to close
um
1573 okay I'm I am ready to do HB 16
1969 relative to restricting data
sharing through the state immunization
registry um is there anyone in the crowd
who's here specifically for
15 98 or
1593 where you would appreciate
me doing those first so that you can
speak and
go is there anyone for those three bills
do M Mr weer you you're going to stick
around because there's some it stuff
there when we get to
them okay uh Mr Mr
K you're you're here for 1593 if we need
you but you don't you're not here to
because you have something specific you
want to put on the
record so so representative Leon um
actually Mr chairman I sent some
language to OS as an amendment to 1669
so I have no problem dealing with the
other bills sooner I'll let you know
when that comes in oh if that's helpful
sure okay thank you okay representative
Stringham uh Alex uh Alex's uh Amendment
uh was sent in uh along with a change
recommended um by um Mr White and looks
like that that one was was prepared so
there is an amendment that could be
reviewed for 1593 if you want to do that
so so let's go ahead and do that I'm
going to open on
1593 it it's relatively short Amendment
so I'm just going to uh let everyone
read for a minute
this this this is uh the shall therefore
be referred to as the stringam amendment
1055 so representative stringman
stringman Stringham would you please
summarize uh what caused this amendment
and what you think it does well I'd ask
for some help with Alex I will say that
one of the changes uh the last line of
paragraph two says any any unexpended
funds shall lapse to the general fund
used to say July 1st 2025 and now says
June 30th
2025 uh Finance felt like if the monies
had to be held that would put it into
the next bium and uh moving it up by one
day uh that uh what a difference to day
makes actually does make a difference
there um in terms of the other wording
uh changes I'd prefer to have Alex talk
to U Mr kbis if if you could so we're
all struggling with your last name
so kbis yeah so Mr kbis would you come
talk to us special Cas we
call good afternoon Alex kbis
representing the area agencies yes
there's three changes to this amendment
uh representative Stringham there's
mentioned the first one which was the I
believe online 9 which changes July 1st
to June 30th it also on line six we
changed it to in the in the bill as it
came over from Health and Human Services
it said the the fiscal year ending on
line six it said for the fiscal year
ending June 30th 2024 so we changed it
to the bium ending June 30th
2025 and then really the the big change
is those were just technical issues that
DHHS had pointed out and I think they're
correct to get those updated which we've
done the PO
it it is kind of a policy change
different from what had come over from
Health and Human Services but I think it
addresses the Chairman's point about why
should children with disabilities be
treated differently than you know other
other individuals who have recreational
needs and so this bill would only apply
this amendment would make the program
only apply to adults and the theory is
that children with disabilities who are
in school have more opportuni unties
because they're in they're in school or
in special education they would have
recreational more recreational
opportunities than someone who was an
adult so that that is the the big change
here that this would only make the
program applicable to adults who've
either graduated or exited the school
system thank you for that if if I could
re rephrase what I I think I said uh I I
I just wanted to make sure that what we
were doing here we could take a look we
could talk to uh New Hampshire taxpaying
families that aren't receiving any
benefits and be able to explain and
articulate to them why this program was
fair that it wasn't given that it wasn't
helping their family directly and so I
think this that's what motivated this is
to try to answer the question for New
Hampshire taxpaying
families why this population why is this
fair and reasonable and is is that yes
okay and I and I think the the the
reason would be that as I tried to
explain last week that these are
individuals who in many cases are just
on Social Security maybe they have a
very very part-time job and they don't
have the income and their families
have they're getting older you know
they're they're in their 70s should
should someone who has a parent in their
70s be responsible for their adult
child's you know recreational needs so
that that the bill has has really been
uh there's been a lot of compromises
along the way originally it was a
million doll appropriation it's been cut
in half originally it was a continually
appropriated fund we were going to stand
up rules now it's only basically a year
and a half program that'll expire and
we'll have to start over again in the
next bium we put a cap of $600
originally there was no cap in there and
now we're making it applicable only to
adults who've left school so that we
have U you know made a lot of
accommodations you know understanding
that this is obviously an unusual
request in the off budget
cycle so so because um this this
amendment uh restricts it to adults only
um what what's Your Gut tell you about
what it does to that
500,000 I'm not I'm not you might be
able to reduce it a little bit I I if
you give me a little more time I could
try to get some information on age how
about till next wed till next Monday not
afternoon sure I will try to get some
information about utilization in the
past based on age do does your instinct
tell you that it'll be sign
significantly different than 500,000 I
depends what you mean by significant uh
100,000 I I would say probably not more
than 100,000 all right
yeah okay um are there questions for go
go ahead representative Leon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr Kus for
being here with us um I I I like the way
that this amendment is going thanks for
cleaning up some of the language we had
in HHS um when we're looking at this
population are they primarily composed
of people who are getting the Social
Security and cont actually required to
pay for most of their services with that
Social
Security yes so um exactly so if you're
I I tried to give this example last week
suppose that you're in a staffed
residence you run by an area agency or a
different vendor who who contracts with
the state uh they they give I think all
but $74 a month of their social security
goes to room and board because Medicaid
does not cover room and board so uh that
that really goes to their food and their
shelter their their social security and
as I said some of them do try to work
part-time jobs if they're able to but
they uh and some of them obviously have
families that that can help and and
they're not going to be asking for this
this is really for those those
situations where uh you they don't have
those families that are able to to chip
in for for some of these recreational
Services uh and again the the families
throughout their lives really you know
have gone above and beyond because we
know that this population requires a lot
of family support and that's really kind
of a backbone of the system you know but
at some point U you know those families
have a limited ability as they as the
caregivers age to be able to to help out
and as I said if you're in your 30s your
parents are in their 70s how much longer
can they continue to contribute to pay
for these things so that's what this is
trying to get at um thank you and if I
can do a followup um since this won't is
isn't designed to continue into the next
budget cycle would it be reasonable to
ask to have information on the
utilization whether they're people who
are on social security or if they're in
any other population so we can really
understand what we're doing so we can
make sure we craft this well um when we
come back to this next year yes I mean
again as the this is another point I
didn't bring up originally I think the
department was going to administer this
program and and they if you look at the
original fiscal not they were going to
need a part-time staff person so this
requires them to contract it out and and
I would be happy to work on some
language that would require that
contractor to issue a report that the
next legislature can review so we would
have some really good data by by
separating it out we're actually G to
it's going to be a lot easier for me to
get you answers on on utilization on age
on what type of services because in the
past as you heard this was all sort of
buried into the budgets and we have to
go in by hand that's why it's hard for
us to get good data on this right now
thank you that'd be very helpful Mr
W good afternoon again members of the
committee Nathan white Chief Financial
Officer um I just want to point out a
couple of technical timing issues on
utilization if we go out to bid for this
we'll have to develop an RFP an RFA
whatever it might be post it and then go
through the contract Contracting process
um so number one is we wouldn't have the
utilization figures for the agency
budget in August number two is by the
time that contract goes livees
potentially you know six months down the
road and the legislative phase starts at
the house phase you may only have about
two months of utilization at that point
in time so they probably won't be a lot
of great information going into the
state fiscal year 2627 budget for this
purpose um thank you and thank you for
that information is it possible just to
Simply administer these through the area
agencies that are already provid proving
services for it for this
population we would need to Soul Source
those contracts and if there's
legislative language that would help or
those amendments probably more so if
there's legislative language that would
help direct us to do that that's
certainly helpful that way we don't come
to GNC and say this was our soul soul
Source request based on our
interpretation that legislature wants us
to do but if it's in writing that's
certainly a little
easier would it be possible to get some
sort of language like that I know I'm
just a substitute here but that seems
like would be help so much more thank
you um so have you've seen this
amendment the Stringham Amendment yes
okay do do you do you have um any issues
with the new proposed dates on line six
and line nine no no I I think the
changes are um are consistent with with
the way we typically appropriate funds
so thank you appreciate it so so uh
representative Stringham there's been
some conversation here about maybe an
amendment to the amendment do you do you
are you tracking it do you do you think
you can work with people to give us one
more shot at this for for Monday
absolutely and um U Mr White if you
could help with soul Source language
that would accelerate and help you out
uh once the bill is enacted I would
appreciate
it are there other questions on on where
are we
1593 anyone any else you want to say the
only thing I would say is you know hope
my hope is that we'd be able to get
under contract maybe in November and
that might give us five to six months of
data at least maybe towards the end of
the house phase so it to the extent Soul
sourcing would help speed things up but
but that was my original thought when we
were going to go to Contracting is maybe
November 1st we could get this up and
running so personally I hate Soul
sourcing I mean you really need to have
a strong justification in my mind for a
soul source and I I I I'm not sure that
this meets a threshold for that um but
maybe we could talk about that um um
okay so thank you for your work on this
and I know uh it's been a lot of changes
and I appreciate you sticking with it so
thank you and thank you Mr
W if there's nothing else I'm going to
close
1593 all right that leaves us down to
two I'm going to I'm going to ask uh
well three actually because 1669 were
waiting for the amendment to come across
the line so I'm going to turn the gavl
over to representative Mooney and she's
going to chair our work session on
1598 thank you Mr chairman again good
afternoon to members and to those
watching online and in the audience this
opens the work session on House Bill
1598 an act relative to the Department
of Health and Human Services management
of Social Security payments and veterans
benefits for children in foster
care want to remind the committee first
and foremost that this uh came out with
an ought to pass recommendation out of
Children and Family Law 12 to one
and then on a Voice vote through the
entire house on February 1st
2024 uh the first work session on this
bill was last week and it's a deep Bill
there is no doubt about that A New
Concept for New Hampshire to adopt lots
of questions lots of details lots of
information since we last met various
and very specific questions were
submitted to
DHHS and I know that legal assistance
and also disabilities
rights has worked very heavily on uh
some details that need to be ironed out
related to this bill there's also an
individual here who expertise is on
Social Security and its benefits and
would also like to weigh in and perhaps
take questions with regards to that
aspect of it is that individual here
thank
you okay to start we're benefited by the
fact that the prime sponsor is here with
us and that is a huge plus when a
division in finance is taking on a bill
is to hear it from this Prime sponsor
what it does what needs to be done and
what the recommendation should be so
with that I'm going to recognize
representative walner for any comments
you may want to make about your bill
House Bill
well we did have a public hearing last
week and I introduced the bill um I
guess what I said last week was
that several months ago I was surprised
to learn that um in New Hampshire we
actually when children go into um the
care of the state either for foster care
or residential care if they have a
Social
Security um benefit the state actually
keeps that benefit while the child is in
care um most of these children or all of
these children um
have very serious disabilities you do
not get Social Security as a child
unless you have serious serious
disabilities
or their parent has
died and so these are some of our really
neediest children and now they find
themselves in foster care or out taken
from their families into a residential
situation um so these are kids that
really end up what it ends up basically
happening is that they're actually
paying for their own foster care and
many states are moving towards changing
this policy and New Hampshire actually
several um years ago
had a policy where parents while CH
while children were in foster care in
the care of the state the parents were
build for the care and few I think two
or three years ago we changed that
policy um so we no longer do um charge
families while their children are in um
out of home
placement and the only what I could see
is the only group that's really left
paying for their own care are the the
children who have these disability um
incomes and it is complicated I won't um
gloss over that I've learned a lot about
it from um a number of people and I
think that what would really be helpful
is if we had
um the person from Social Security the
person who really has expertise in
Social Security help us understand some
of this legal assistance has done a lot
of work as has a disabilities rights um
clinic so and they're all here I think
and they have posed a series of
questions to the department um which
we're hoping that the department can
come up and answer today thank you thank
you representative walner five specific
questions I'd like to focus on and hear
from everybody the order is Up For
Debate so and I would like this to be a
real work session with regards to we'll
take one question at a time hopefully do
this in about half an hour and then uh
any feedback either from us legislators
or those in the audience that have an
interest in this bill so representative
walner has uh brought to light our
expert on Social Security would you like
to open with any particular comments
overviews or thoughts related to the
bill before I start diving into the five
specific questions or you could wait and
weigh in one question at a time at your
desire okay very good for those not uh
hearing on the mic she would prefer uh
perhaps to do either but maybe with a
preference of one question at a time
that being said let's start with the
first question and I would ask that
everybody who's interested in weighing
in on the question to please us get
close so we can make this move okay
question number
one should she read her name into the
record yes and if you could read your
name into the record that would be
great
if you could click it on until you see
red light can you hear me now yes thank
uh my name is Megan Dylan I am the
public benefits project co-director for
New Hampshire legal assistance I'm a
non- attorney I am certified as a non-
attorney rep to represent claimants and
federal disability claims and I've been
doing that with an HLA for a little over
10 years representing both individuals
and children and federal disability
claims overp payments and termination
matters uh just for a little bit of
background
thank you very much and I know you come
very highly recommended I've heard
fantastic things about you your work and
your knowledge so we have the exact
right person here if anyone has
questions related to Social Security
number
one how
many foure eligible children are
currently receiving SSI benefits and
what is the rationale for the
anticipated loss of
4E funding
so would you like to have them start and
then you okay could someone from DHHS
please come read your name into the
record and discuss the answer to that
question and once you do we'll open it
up to anyone else who has thoughts on
the
question good good afternoon my name is
Attorney Laura young I'm litigation
Council for Department of Health and
Human
Services and so going into question one
uh the department collects title E
Benefits uh for approximately 25
children in lie of SSI and that's
because we re we can receive more
funding from that title 4E than if we
collected the full SSI for those
children so we're able to get more
funding in that sense uh the department
um it also claims fore funding for
administrative costs that's allowed
under
the title and we believe there would
likely be a reduction in administrative
costs connected to a reduction in
overall taking fore
funds okay approximately 25
children that's correct again I I give
the warning that we're we're dealing
with a lot of in andout I think you
heard say me say this last time meaning
our we we welcome that right we want
kids to come in and out um of our care
and in different situations so when I
say 25 that is not again a stagnant same
25 children we're really trying to do
our best to give you averages even
though that's that's very difficult you
know we could have an inflex next month
of children of an additional 20 children
we don't know what's coming that's
what's been very difficult uh for this
process of answering these what seem to
be simple questions is that it's very
layered so it is 25 but again that's
considering the in and out and that we
don't know what each day may
bring thank you Miss Dylan anything to
add to
that um I would just add that I don't
think it is a fluctuating number she
said I can certainly understand kids
coming in and out but primarily um we
still don't have a good sense of how
many of those children are actually
receiving supplemental security income
SSI which is a welfare or needs-based
benefit under Social Security
versus title 2 benefits which are
dependent benefits so children qualify
for title 2 benefits only if a qualified
parent um qualifies for those benefits
so they can receive them under the title
to that means that a parent who is an
insured worker who has qualified with
their work earnings over time their
dependent child can qualify for a
benefit under their record there may
also be survivor benefits a deceased
parent who is also an insured worker
where the child could qualify for for
survivor benefits those benefits are not
subject to income and resource
requirements whatsoever title 2 only and
therefore there are very fewer reporting
and administrative requirements for
those types of benefits you don't have
to do an annual reporting for title 2
there's no impact on income or resource
limitations for those students I I'm
sorry for those kids the only thing that
would impact that if if somehow the
parent became ineligible and suddenly
the child wouldn't receive that benefit
anymore that would be the primary impact
on whether a child receives title 2 or
continues to be eligible for title 2
which is quite different from SSI where
there are more parameters around
reporting because it's a need-based
program and just for clarity I know we
both talk in title two and title 16 but
just that's really if when you
practicing Social Security Title two uh
that is SSDI title 16 is SSI I just I
know Megan we both speak that language
and so when we say title two title 16
we're talking about those just for um to
help
out very good and may remind you
attorney young you said the word simple
no one else no one no one here on this
panel used that uh word so that's yours
okay any questions from those on
division three related to this
topic okay M
Rosenberg yes have a seat
please I um just for the record I'm
Karen Rosenberg I'm the policy director
at the disability rights Center um the
question I would ask the department to
pursue further is um this assertion that
if the department doesn't take the 4E
maintenance payments that they would
also lose administrative payments that's
not I'm not an expert in that field I've
been trying to get a handle on that
information from other folks so it might
just be something helpful for the
Department to look further into maybe
get some direct guidance from D us DHHS
about that um that just is just a
question
really okay Miss Young are you amendable
to that certainly I can look into that
and get and get back I don't think um
just to be clear I was when I it was a
reduction not a complete Absolution we
that was what we are thinking but we can
come back and look at that thanks
I would also just add one thing we're
looking at the um total potential loss
in SSI benefits um the maximum SSI
payment in 2024 is 943 per month um the
statistical data from Social Security
from 2022 that was reported the annual
report said that the average SSI payment
to a child was 685 per month so the
amount a child can get can vary
depending on what other income resources
or specific taxs pertain to that child
so it's not clear also how many of those
kids are receiving the maximum SSI
payment or not
currently okay thank you anything
further we're going to move to question
two all right question two how many
additional 4E eligible children are
anticipated to be found eligible per
year for SSI benefits and how did the
department reach that calc
ation Miss Young would you like to start
on that uh sure we we um we had these
questions you know ahead of time and we
tried to provide our best answers this
was something we did not feel
comfortable
speculating uh about at this at this
time we already provided the
approximately 25 children right now but
in terms of how many could be found
eligible per year is we could not uh
spend speculate to that to give you an
an accurate number uh we instead felt
that hiring a consultant to assist with
this and other questions would be the
best in providing any kind of guess uh
because that's what it would be right
now is a guess and we want to be very
careful about that when it comes to
funding especially to just a
guess thank you Miss Young Miss
Dylan um yes I would just I would just
say that um folks should be aware that
uh in terms of CH I can't speak
specifically to the 4E that's not my
area of expertise but regarding SSI um
again according to the annual
statistical report that was re released
by social security for 2022 there were
approximately
1,67 kids under meaning folks under 18
receiving SSI um in 2022 it's a very
small number um there is very very
strict medical criteria that a child
must meet to qualif qualify for
disability um under
SSI primarily they have to have a severe
impairment or combination of impairments
is is expected to last or has lasted a
period of 12 consecutive months um and
they generally have to meet a marked or
extreme listing um under multiple
domains of functioning for children that
means that they assess how they perform
in school how they cannot perform in
school how they do self-care things like
feeding themselves dressing themselves
capacity children have to be considered
in two marked areas or one extreme to
qualify for SSI so it's very difficult
generally for children to qualify for
SSI a diagnosis alone is not
sufficient thank you representative
walner followed by representative hle
I'm sorry
Lon representative
walner thank you um would you give the
number of children again this was
according to 2022 the annual statistical
report from Social Security
Administration
1,617 in New Hampshire under 18
receiving SSI
okay and I think just to be sure
everyone understands the bill only
addresses children who are in state care
not so this doesn't not have anything to
do with all the total not not
considering children who are in
placement or in care right so that's the
number for kids just living with their
parents who may qualify or in other
familial situations that are not in
placement so it just gives you a sense
of how difficult it is for children to
qualify and you know how many
potentially out of the children that are
filtering in and out of the system the
chances of them qualifying meeting all
of the parameters for this very strict
medical total disability program are not
high thank you representative Lon for a
question um it was very similar it's
answered thank you than you
Miss
Rosenberg I also want to point out that
um my other my colleague from New
Hampshire legal systems is here um she
may want to introduce herself good
afternoon sorry good afternoon Michelle
wangren from New Hampshire legal
assistant and I apologize I'm a few
minutes
late did you get that name Mr clerk if
you could for the record microphone
close through your
mouth here we go Michelle
wangren it's w n g r i
n so and and just to put this number
that U Megan was speaking about in
further context like in New Hampshire
right now there are something around
30,000 children who qualify for special
education so that just gives you an idea
and we only have 1,600 children under
and to qualify for special education you
could be under 22 so now we have only
1,600 children Statewide under 18 who
qualify for SSI so it is a teeny tiny
percentage of children that we're
talking
about
understood anyone further on this
question
two okay let's move to question three
Miss Young oh I just I wanted to make
sure given that the 30,000 in special
education keep in mind just as as Megan
pointed out this is a means-based
program meaning SSI you have to meet
certain income criteria so just I don't
want you to take the 30,000 it is I
absolutely agree it is very difficult to
get on SSI but I just wanted to make
sure that's clear as well it is a means
programing you have to meet very strict
income
eligibility okay thank you for that
question
three how did the department calculate
the
$74,000
loss in 4E funds
that was
mentioned as I recall in the fiscal note
the fiscal note is shocking for many
reasons this is one so if we could have
an answer to that that would be
fantastic Mr
White good afternoon members of the
community white Chief finance officer
with the Department of Health and Human
Services
um the
74,000 was one component of the total
impact that we would expect um if this
bill is to pass um there's currently
25 again and I just want to caveat this
figure as these numbers are constantly
moving every day um for roughly 25
children um we would expect
approximately about little over
$700,000 impact because we're currently
claiming 4E for them in the event we
claimed SSI and you and as we do today
where we do collect SSI
we use the SSI towards the um payment
for treatment and other services that
those children would receive um so were
we to claim SSI for those children as
intended by the bill we would no longer
be able to claim that 700 and so odd
thousand um and we would still have a
treatment need the the children would
still need services and we would need to
get General funds to pay for those
services
Miss Rosenberg oh I'm sorry no m
Michelle Michelle wer from New Hampshire
legal assistance again one thing I would
say about that is so we're talking about
25 children here um and what I don't see
in the bill is a requirement that the
department not claim for a funding and I
know that I previously Circ circulated
to at least some members of the
committee um an article about how the
intersection between um Social Security
benefits SSI and 4E work and the way
that my understanding is that it works
um and if there is another 4E specialist
that knows something else that's I'd
love to hear that but in the documents
that I've reviewed the way it works is
that there's no bar on claiming both for
benefits and Social Security if you do
claim both however and a child receives
fory funding their social security is
reduced dollar for dooll
um so if the department were to receive
say I don't know $4,000 per month in for
refunding which may be you know probably
in the ballpark of what they might
receive um for a child in um an
institution um their SSI would be
reduced to zero so they would still have
the SSI on file if they were to return
home or to a less restrictive setting
they may receive it but the department
would still receive receive its fory
money while that child is in
institutional care and so if this you
know if there needs to be a
clarification that the department at
least for children in institutional
settings where we know that the amount
of $4 is going to be High um to to
clarify that in those situations the
department um may claim 40 funding
simultaneously with SSI benefits I think
that would be a nice clarification to
make sure that the state is not losing
out on those $4 but again there is no
bar on claiming both and it's the amount
of so um SSI that has reduced dollar for
dollar not the amount of fory benefits
now of course we know that these are
children with extraordinary needs um and
you know one might argue that being an
Institutional care um recognizes that
that is an extraordinary need at the
same time when you're talking about a
child in foster home
um those extraordinary needs are still
present and so when we're talking about
kids in foster homes where the amount of
$40 claimed by the state is going to be
less we would honestly like to see um
those children receive their their uh
SSI dollars so that the foster home has
access to meet their extraordinary needs
um might they need some specialized um
care in the home might they need um
specialized therapies and that sort of
thing it would be really nice to see
those children have access to those
dollars to meet their extraordinary
needs but again I believe and the
department can please correct me if I'm
wrong that the vast majority of those
$40 come from children and institutional
care not children in community- based
settings and again as the bill is
written there even for children in in um
community based settings there would be
no bar on the state claiming uh for any
funds under this the bill as written
there would just be that dollar for
dooll
reduction okay okay representative
Edwards thank you I think you may have
actually answered my question in your
very last sentence um it it it it it it
sounds like the answer to number three
on this question document do you have
that in front of you yes okay that that
if we can apply simultaneously for the
4E money in addition to the SSI that the
answer to number three may actually be
different that Z it would be zero so
instead of 74,000 we'd be talking Z zero
so no loss from no loss do Mr White may
I yes M Mr White do you have a an
observation on
that the challenge is is we we
can't and and this this is based off of
um our understanding and uh coming from
Decades of experience on the financial
team um that that have historically
manage this historically our
understanding based on our conversations
with our Auditors is that we're not able
to claim both which is why we're
basically seeing some general fund
impact and I think what's really
important here is not to focus
necessarily whether it's the 74,000 here
or the 1.4 million um the other impact
for the total 2 million is from a policy
perspective we are going to have some
impact on General funds and again I'm
I'm I'm speaking of it I'm speaking at
the through the financial lens whether
it's $1.5 million general fund hit or $3
million general fund hit depending on
the year and utilization we will have
some impact so whether it's 500,000 this
year and a million dollars next year you
know ultimately what this really comes
down to is we know we'll need additional
General funds and we know this is a
policy decision um I I just kind of want
to level set the the the floor with with
that statement um because when we don't
know for example when we start to
prepare our budget for the next year
this coming August which we'll submit in
September we'll be making certain
assumptions about utilization we'll be
making certain assumptions about what
we'll need in federal funds and what
we'll need in general funds and so I
know that we're getting very much into
the weeds and details here but I think
it's important not to lose sight of the
big picture ultimately it's a policy
decision that will have some impact on
General funds and we just don't know how
much it this is our best estimate based
on on the information that we have which
isn't necessarily kept in our financial
system for this type of analysis which
is part of the reason why in question
three we were recommending uh some type
of further analysis relative to this um
because this is the best information
that we have
available representative
hle thank you you mentioned that you had
spoken with the Auditors on this and
they LED you to believe that you could
not concurrently ask for both funds is
that a document that was put in writing
anywhere that could be supplied I I I I
tried to Contex to to clarify um
representative H I tried to CL try to
contextualize that within the experience
of the team so we John and I we've been
having conversations um with with my
Deputy CFO who has 27 years experience
working in this area and is very
well-versed and it's her understanding
based on those years of experience that
we cannot claim both however um if we're
more than happy to try to examine that
further but in the event that you know
maybe if you could claim a dollar of SSI
but you may still have additional 4E
that would probably just be a further
administrative burden so we would just
need to recognize that but that's how we
were interpreting this to
date follow up thank you if there was a
chance to ask the auditor that worked
presumably the auditor coming out of the
federal government that you're working
with no uh so so the auditors uh the
legislative budget assistant hires uh
the the the the single Statewide auditor
that has historically been
KPMG Miss Dylan your mic is on did you
have further
information no I would just I would just
point out again that in in terms of I
don't know what in terms of the auditor
is saying but for the purposes of
children collecting SSI and SSDI
benefits as long as they're within the
parameters of that income limit of that
94 43 they can collect both so most of
the time those title do title two
benefits the the benefits they receive
under the record of a parent would be
significantly lower allowing a child to
collect both benefits at the same time
um and for the purposes of the 4E I
can't imagine what other bar would exist
other than Meeting those income and
resource requirements to collect both
benefits I haven't seen anything that
would prohibit it otherwise my kiddos
have received other forms of payment
sometimes a parent qualifies for a
pension that's below the 943 and they
can collect that on behalf of the
deceased parent in addition to their SSI
benefit so as long as really the
financial barriers are the only thing
that prohibit SSI recipients from
claiming other benefits they may be
qualified
for yes representative
Edwards okay so um it's it's outside of
the boundaries of what we're trying to
do uh to get ready for a vote on this
bill but it does seem like maybe for the
good of the state if Mr White can get
whatever documentation that indicates
that we can claim or ask for both that
that may improve our own collection
Services internal to the department I
I'm not saying it will I'm just saying
it might so so if we could just double
check because that sounds like you know
we could fund some of these other bills
with the 74,000 so it is kind of
relevant to what we're doing and and Mr
chair I just I just like to
um I really appreciate that question and
I and I do think that it's a probably a
pretty simple answer and I would just
want to caution the Committee Against
spending $200,000 to get the answer
because I do think that that's a basic
statutory question that I would like the
department to investigate prior to
delaying the bill in any way spending
200,000 $200,000 to get the answer to
that
question Miss Young do you have a
comment
I of I of course disagree I I don't
think it's just answering that question
and I also think you have multiple
people who work with this and we
all understand this title 4E a little
differently based on our experiences
this is not a simple statute to read
there is nothing simple about social
security fore is part of the Social
Security Act just so that we all know
it's all part of social security so I
think what getting a consultant gives
you gets you and gets The Advocates
involved in this is the best answers
that we can give not only on funding but
on what we can do maybe even better than
we're doing now and what we can do to
change policy in a good way that serves
the kids the best we can um and in the
best way with the the best possible
funding whether it be more or less you
know that's what the consultant can look
at uh and see I I think even answering
these questions you're you're seeing
this that shows how much thought has to
go into this and how much limitations we
have right now on this timing to do that
and so that that's why we feel the
consultant to come in and help us and um
and help The Advocates involved as well
get the answers get them right and let
us do a good job if this is going to be
a policy
change I just want to add one thing
which is that I think that um it's
interesting to note that even currently
under current policy and under Social
Security regulations the department is
already required to account to the
Social Security Administration about how
the children's Social Security benefits
are spent so there so I'm I think that
the department already has people on
board who are effectuating this
responsibility and if it comes down to
you know I I think my understanding is
that it's possible to claim both and
it's just going to be a reduction in the
Social Security benefits for children on
SSI but if that's not true um and it's
not feasible to draw to collect both SSI
and for E Benefits there's probably a
pretty simple fix that could be put into
this bill that would exclude um the
requirement that the department take SSI
benefits during the time that the child
is in a residential institutional
placement um I I think I I think we
could all come together and probably
come up with something that would meet
that concern I think we just need to
know the answer to the first question
one question to look at might be you
know I the we're talking about the kids
that are coming in and there's that
application for the kids that are coming
in that are already on SSI is the
department taking them off SSI to claim
4E or are they just getting that dollar
for dooll reduction
now do we
know
probably something to be looked into
thank you representative Edwards this
the question for the chair um it's it
seems to me like we're we're learning
things uh that would allow us to um put
forward an amendment to this bill that
would impr improve it some and so if if
if I'm hearing this right um do we have
a legislator on in division through
three that is taking the lead on working
with the folks much like representative
walner is on the other Bill to to to to
create try to create an
amendment it's a it's a tasking issue a
delegation issue or do we have anyone
identified who wants to own an
amendment I believe that uh the answer
to your question is I don't know of any
right now however representative walner
is the prime sponsor I'm also on the
bill I'm sure we can work with all of
the parties here uh to create such an
amendment that you mention okay that
being said uh we've been at this now for
almost 40 minutes and we do have other
bills on the docket my intention is to
go through the next two questions uh
with that being said uh in the similar
manner that we are now and then
rescheduling this for the follow-up
items that we have discovered along the
way as well as any particular Amendment
language that we come up with for the
next work session or perhaps even one
after that okay we're going to go now to
question
four how did the department calculate
the
$1.4 million loss in federal SSI Revenue
also in the fiscal note Mr
White this was the actual SSI uh Revenue
that was earned in state fiscal year 23
for the initial fiscal note um the
department actually received think about
160 fiscal note requests this year which
was a record and we had about 5 days to
turn those around so we try to provide
the best information possible in the
initial fiscal note this is the updated
revised uh fiscal note here and again
this is based on the actual State fiscal
year 23 Revenue uh were the bill to pass
um we would need an equivalent amount of
General
funds uh to uh to maintain that in state
fiscal year uh 26 and each year
thereafter
so thank you for that any followup or
thoughts questions anyone around the
table or in the
center okay moving on then question
number five what are the specific
additional obligations triggered by this
bill Beyond dcf's current obligations
under Department policy and what are the
expected duties of each additional
needed staff
member Miss Young yes so today we deal
with those children coming in who are
already receiving a benefit this bill
would us to deter would require us to
determine whether or not children who do
not have a currently receive a benefit
would be eligible and then take that a
step further um and Safeguard it and
then it also requires that every year
thereafter should it be a child that
remains in in care uh what that goes
into is right now we have an accounting
process that and that's required by
Social Security and it goes to cost of
care you've heard us say that so that's
in and out right um the difference would
be as a fiduciary of money coming in
that is not in and out and going to cost
of care you're dealing with fiduciary
decisions that is not a a simple task
and it looks different for every kid
those fiduciary decisions could be a
daily ask of what needs does that kid
have it could go into protecting those
needs protecting the needs putting it in
a trust putting it in an account of some
sort that does not absolve any kind of
fiduciary decisions that requires a
monitoring process of making the
decisions we kind of talked about that
at the last session so I don't want to
get into those details but also it
requires the for the in andout of making
sure that new kids come in eligibility
we have to decide what's going on that
could easily change um for from DayDay
from Kid to Kid it also can change given
the kids circumstances I think um we
talked about how difficult it is to get
on SSI that could be a difficult Road in
terms of appeals and having an attorney
that is monitoring that making sure it
happens it also could be someone a staff
person monitoring when a kid gets into
care and gets the care that they need
that means we've
to go forward with Social Security and
that takes quite a bit of work as well
um so what we looked at when we
determined the Staffing for this was all
that combined of we have kids going in
and out we have kids are going daily
fiduciary decisions daily safeguarding
decisions and then also decisions about
who can manage those trusts for example
is a state going to be a trustee of a
Special Needs Trust or we going to be
able to find someone else be IT
professional or a family member and
those are not easy decisions I think we
have all seen cases of things going
wrong with fucher Duty and it is not a
light decision-making process and so we
have purposely staffed it in a way that
we can make sure that we know where the
money is where it's going and that it's
going properly and being safeguarded and
that's really what you see the Staffing
when you have a legal you need an
attorney to do that um you have to have
an attorney that knows not only social
security law but you have to have an
attorney that knows probate for example
I am fiduciary duties and then on top of
that Staffing that attorney with
paralegals and staff that can
continually monitor the children in care
again think of this going in and out um
and making sure that it's being taken
care of and that's that's the best we
can do to kind of give the commit the
big picture of what we were thinking
when we staffed this very purposefully
very heavily because of the heavy
fiduciary duty
involved representative H thank you so
in a hypothetical scenario you have a
child who comes into the system right
and is eligible for social security
benefits and then for some reason
whether it was a temporary illness
temporary medical issue whatever drove
them into that state they are no longer
eligible a year or two later but if they
were at six at the time are we still
managing those funds up through the time
they're 18 before they have access to
them where how does that work are you
talking about right now or under this
bill under the proposed bill so under
the I just want to make sure I
understand the fact scenario so we have
someone who came in who was receiving
SSI correct um they now probably thanks
of Social Security um and continuing a
disability review they they no longer
eligible correct that's right so now we
have to find somewhere for that money to
go that we've safeguarded right and you
hold on to that until they're 18 is that
what the plan would be the bill
envisions safeguarding that for um
benefits purposes and in that it would
really depend how much money was
involved we want to be have to be really
careful about for example Medicaid
benefits not having too much to that
that kid's name but yes the idea in this
this bill would be that the state
safeguards it by either putting it into
some kind of Safeguard account as long
as they're disabled um at that point
that you make it or receiving it yes and
holding it until they're out of
care okay okay representative Edwards
was
next
um representative
Edwards so this last sentence in the
answer to question five is the one that
leaves me the most concerned where it
says that the complexities of managing
trusts and other unique accounts will
increase
workload um I don't think that we do
anything in this area currently from a
state's perspective of administering uh
accounts for uh our citizens and if
that's if that's
true if it's not true you correct me but
if it is true it seems to me like we
have to invent almost a a banking Branch
to to do this and the and and making
sure that we identify all of the federal
and state laws that we would now have to
comply with that seems like it still
needs it would need to be done and then
the policies and procedures and the
training and the hiring this just seems
like a massive part of the bill that I I
I I'm sort of just concerned that we do
not underestimate do do you have any
comments comments on that I think that
is accurate I will say we do have state
institutions that have personal needs
accounts I think of for instance Glen
Cliff home um if someone is on Medicaid
which Glen Cliff I believe almost
everyone is on Medicaid they get 70 I
think it might have gone up to $90 a
month um that they can keep you know for
their accounts I will to get that caveat
that the that is a state institution so
technically we do manage those funds
though they normally have a guardian
that does so in terms of but in terms of
having a collective State account that's
the one I I thought of after we met last
but yes this would be the state getting
into the fiduciary Services business um
which is different than what we do
now different in the sense that it uh
causes us to need to comply with
additional federal law um and if
so do we just think that or do we have
we identified new federal law we'd have
to comply with we already act as
fiduciary in terms of personal um or as
representative pay for those kids like
we talked about it's in and out though
right we have regular audits with social
security for that right now so we meet
that we would have to meet that again as
an organizational representative P but
it's it's a it's different it's not just
in and out uh so we would have to meet
those regulations in terms of others um
we you heard me talk about meeting
Medicaid U making sure that Medicaid
funding that those those dollars are
safe started in a way um and
in and I have to come back and think
about the different you know you asked
about Federal but then we also have
state expectations of our probate court
system that it's a question of whether
we would have to open a guardianship
over the estate to even be able to
create a Special Needs Trust for a kid
because right now it's guardianship over
the person uh that's that's really you
think about over the person is you know
where someone lives Medical care
decisions of a kid now we're getting
into financial decisions and I think we
would open up a world that the court
would be very mindful because these
these kids are under the jurisdiction of
of the court in terms of guardianship if
they're in care for the most part um we
would want to make sure that we're in
line with that I do not know I know you
mentioned bank I do not know um if we
would be subject to any kind of banking
or anything like that that's something
I'd have to look into thank you madam
chair thank you for the
answer thank you and Miss
Rosenberg M take oh I'm sorry it looks
like fighting over it so Madam chair and
members of the committee I think this is
becoming um incredibly over complicated
I think it's important to remember the
state receives these benefits becomes
the representative pay and is already
the fiduciary they are already
responsible for using or conserving
these CH these these dollars in the best
interest of the children they are
currently making a choice to reimburse
them themselves with it but they could
make a choice to use it for the child's
day-to-day benefit or conserve it that
is no different they are already a
fiduciary and any of the legal
responsibilities that come with that are
already on them the choice is reimburse
thems or use it for the child and so the
way we envision this if we're using it
for the child or conserving it for the
child that it would go into um a
dedicated account just as they already
do with retroactive benefits that a
child may receive after they become
eligible uh for for um
SSI um which where they're already
managing um specific accounts for the
benefit of children um we see this
working very very similarly where a jppo
could say or or a child protection
worker could say this child child just
broke their glasses for the third time
this month and insurance isn't going to
cover it oh well that's a good use of
this money and there's a an account for
it or this child would really benefit
from equestrian therapy oh there's a
dedicated account for that so we don't
see this as being this complicated
process we don't see this as increasing
the state's fiduciary obligations that
they already have we only see this as
ensuring the money is either used for
the child 's benefit or conserved for
the child's benefit instead of
reimbursing themselves their legal
obligations do not change what they
would have to decide is where to put
that money they could do a special needs
trust but that's a more complicated
expensive process we have able accounts
in New Hampshire which are a much easier
process would somebody have to manage
the um the the withdrawals from them yes
and so could I see you know for um a
hundred or so kids could I see and FTE
maybe you know taking requests for these
this money and and managing you know
approving or denying each request I
could see that but I could see that for
one staff I don't see that for six or
seven staff I think this is becoming
massively overco complicated in a way
that it just doesn't need to be as a
reminder this legislation is modeled
after Arizona law is that true yes do
you know how many administrators manage
their account
perhaps um question we can look at that
I remember looking at the fiscal note I
have it and it was like two or three
yeah it was fewer and and it was I think
for like 1.5 million kids I do remember
that number that the kid the amount of
kids was in the millions representative
Lon um thank you madam chair um this is
definitely a complex topic but as
somebody who is licensed by the SEC for
far too long the idea that managing the
funds in one way is the same as managing
the funds so that they can be taken
responsibly to these children as they're
adult as they're out of the system um
just brings up all sorts of red flags to
me that management of preserving their
assets and they're capital for their
future opportunities is entirely
different different than managing it for
their current custodial care as part of
the state and um I I can't tell you all
the details of it but my red plags from
all my SEC work really really has huge
mind fields for this so I think we need
to make make sure that we understand
just what just what liability the state
is taking on managing These funds for
these children Megan would you I was
just going to say could you explain how
the reporting obligations were so just
to your point and to my colleague's
point I just wanted to say Point Blank
that the state is not obligated to take
on the fiduciary responsibility for
reporting and be the representative pay
for these children in fact the Social
Security regulations and the Palms
manuals make the state organization or
welfare agency sixth or seventh in the
preference line for being the rep paye
for these children I certainly
understand that there are situations
where that maybe the child has no kin
whatsoever that it's appropriate for the
state to do so but in most instances a
child may be in care and still have a
very competent relative aunt Uncle
adoptive parent whatever the situation
may be that could manage those funds for
them becoming a representative payes
specific to Social Security and you
apply to become a rep paye so the state
does not have to do that and the Social
Security Administration has an
obligation to vet find and appoint a
representative PE that is the federal
agency's responsibility not the states
so they could choose very much so to put
the onus back where it belongs on the
federal agency and tell them to find
appropriate payes for these kids many of
which may have a vested emotional
interest in that child as their relative
or relatives friend or close family
member and that's completely possible
and we would eliminate a lot of the
responsibility and the cost associated
with managing those reporting if if
that's done um and that's something that
could be done um in addition to that the
reporting responsibilities again when
we're talking about children who are
recipients of Social Security disability
insurance or a title two benefit versus
supplemental security income are very
different again title 2 benefits don't
require annual reporting they are not an
income or needs based
program so the reporting is much less um
or not required in the same way it is
for SSI and for most SSI kids a
representative paye and this doesn't
apply to parents or relatives who live
with the child anymore are not required
to do an annual reports a state agency
or a welfare agency would be required as
the rep P to do an annual reporting um
it's an online reporting tool um as long
as they are tracking how the child's
expenses are being being used it can all
be submitted at once in one in a
one-time annual report there can be
changes that can occur for children in
care which I certainly understand like
an address change or a name change or
something else that needs to be reported
but again that seems like a low lift in
terms of reporting we report changes for
clients and it's an online tool it's a
simply a written statement to the agency
the address is now this um it just
doesn't feel as cumbersome in the way of
for this many kids and especially they
didn't have the responsibility this is a
voluntary responsibility that the state
is taking on to be the rep paye they
don't have to be um so in that way you
know and for kids you're talking about a
lot less that's involved in the annual
reporting for adults it's a lot more
complicated because adults may be going
back to work adults may be doing more
things that can have impact on resource
and income opening their own bank
accounts that maybe other people aren't
aware of children need adults to do all
of this for them so the fact that things
that are harder to report for adults
because they have the authority to do it
themselves simply can't be done for kids
so that reporting is not as intensive um
so for all of those reasons primarily
thinking that the state should strongly
consider putting the onus back on the
federal agency to find appropriate rep
pay for these children and simply not
choose to take that responsibility on um
if the rep pay is appropriate and can
continue to be appropriate then that
should
happen
okay all
set all right r one thing I also wanted
to call your attention to um some
policies that Michelle werin distributed
at your last work session so the
division of children youth and families
policy manual
1676 talk um if you go to page three of
that um this is the section that
requires them to establish a dedicated
account for any child who has six months
or more past due benefits this comes up
pretty frequently because the Social
Security Administration takes a really
long time to make eligibility
determinations but they already have a
process in place to make decisions about
how to use a child's funds to meet their
extraordinary needs so and it lists you
know what the process is for um you know
creating a dedicated account and what
kinds of um items can may be used from
this dedicated account and what the
reporting requirements are for that so
the division already has a process in
place thank
you likewise I would just say I heard
earlier that that one of the added
obligations is the is an application to
for benefits for CH for all children
coming into the Ben into the system and
currently they are o only um receiving
the Social Security or SSI benefits of
children who already received them again
I just like to point the committee to um
the the that same section of policies um
that which also already requires them to
apply for um Social Security benefits or
SSI benefits for any children going into
out of home care which is exactly in
line with what this bill requires
whether or not they're doing it I don't
know but they have a policy that
requires um investigation of Eligibility
um for each child going into an outof
home placement and again this bill only
requir re Ires an investigation of
eligibility for each child going into
care which I perceive means um out of
home placement but assuming those are in
line the policy is in line with the
statute
already yes Miss Dylan and I would just
point out one more thing as far as the
annual screening um and medical
redeterminations once a child is found
eligible for SSI benefits for themselves
in terms of their own medical
impairments that qualify them Social
Security will review that child not less
than every three years so so every three
years is the maximum period of time that
they're going to look again to see
whether that child qualifies for the
medically continues to qualify medically
for that benefit unless there has been a
major medical change reported or major
medical improvement Social Security is
not going to look at that medical
eligibility again for until about 3
years from the time the child is
approved so I'm not sure that any type
of annual screening medically for a
child would be necessary at all unless
there is a major medical change that you
think now qualifies the child for
disability that didn't exist at the time
that they entered
care okay thank you for that anything
further we're still on question
five
okay that was a jam-packed almost one
hour of um House Bill
1598 so I want to thank everybody for
first of all their time we are very
mindful on this committee as to
everybody's time and how valuable it is
and we try to go as fast and be as uh
concise as we can and sometimes that
doesn't always work out but always know
our intention is the same and that as we
truly appreciate everybody's time and
expertise and sharing information to
help decisions be made appropriately so
again thank you there are some items
that are for followup uh for example uh
question one uh further data from the US
Department of Health and Human Services
question three whether or not 4E and SSI
uh there's a bar on both isn't there
also there was a request for a
dollar-to-dollar
comparison on question
three those are just some of the
follow-ups I have Arizona Personnel on
question five was another one yes
representative priest uh thank you for
taking my question and I apologize for
not being here earlier but I was double
duty today um I would appreciate written
responses from HHR on the questions that
were discussed today thank
you thank you for that representative
priest I believe we have that already uh
if you miss young would take it upon
yourself to either email what has
already been emailed to
me those answers to all of us as they
are or if there are amended versions to
those answers based on today's
discussion whichever one you choose
could you be the person to email that to
all of us here on division
three yes thank
you okay so anything further from the
members all right at this point I'm
going to close the work session on House
Bill 1598 with the full intention that
this will be rescheduled to another work
session through our division 3 chair
thank you
all nice nice work thank you um so the
there are three things I still want to
do uh before wrapping up and I I want to
just for the everyone on the panel to
know that um I I want to impose a hard
stop at 4:15 why 4:15 because we should
be out of the building by 4 to let Janet
go do her stuff and I want to give the
each of the caucuses a chance to talk a
little bit before we uh leave the
building so we'll hard stop at 4:15
caucuses will will meet or not meet
whatever they want to do and um and so
the three things I want to do at this
point is I want to bring up Mr weeders
to uh have us uh hear what he has to say
about uh the it
implications on any of the effective
dates of any of the bills that we've
we've heard or will here still today
which which the only one we haven't even
mentioned yet is
1588 so go
ahead okay for the record Again David
weers Information Services director
DHHS uh as
a chairman if you if I may
1669 can I address the it components for
that one yes this is you now have the
floor okay so we we addressed all the
bills with the exception of HB 1669 and
HB
1588 um from what I can tell but if you
need additional information let me know
for
1669 we based off of the current fiscal
note uh that you have in front of you
that's posted we don't need additional
funding um other than what's already
listed there and we would be in
compliance after 60 days of pass passage
as it is written today the reason why is
we currently do not share data with
other states from the new New Hampshire
immunization information system as of
today we do plan on sharing data in the
future and in order to do that with the
changes in this bill we would need those
the funding to do that changes those
changes but we would not share any data
until such time that the changes were
made
additionally okay so if this bill didn't
get passed and we didn't give you money
to change the system would that mean
that by default we would not be sharing
with other states or or or
regions it would mean that we would be
able to pass administrative rule to
manage how we share data but it wouldn't
necessarily mean we would comply with
the letter of the bill bill as written
so we would manage the administrative
rule to share data with other states as
other states do for immunization
information system data um but the
specifics in the bill um would not
necessarily dictate how our
administrative rule is written okay and
and then if you could just remind me uh
is is is this immunization system is
this the anticipated answer to the
question that's been coming up for a
couple decades now about having an
immunization registry is this is this
the Longs sought solution to what has
been an
ongoing aspect of discussion in the
legislature about having an immunization
database and welcome tell us who you are
so that we get you in the record hi
chairman Abby Rogers legislative L on
for the division of Public Health
Services um I'm here to support with
some information on the immunization
from the immunization program if you
have questions so um just to fill in
that uh eventually um I's or information
um immunization Registries do intend to
share with other states that's sort of
the best practice uh New Hampshire
currently does not do that um and it is
not a priority for the Department to
currently do
that are you familiar with the the
ongoing discussion for about 10 15 20
years about our desire to have an
immunization database and we haven't had
an IT base and so this is this comes
back to my question to make sure that
I'm in line with what I I think I'm
talking about is is this the answer to
the 20 year old question about us
needing an immunization
registry clearly imun immunization
registry is is critically important it
is is that a yes or a no well I'm I I'm
not sure exactly what you're getting at
if you could rephrase the question um
the immunization registry is very
important certainly um patient health
records in the immunization registry
sort of travel as they would like a PA a
patient health record so if you uh went
to college in New Hampshire for example
you might want to have your and you move
back to Maine you'd like to have your
electronic records transferred um we
currently don't do that I think
immunization Registries are moving in
that direction and I understand that
this bill is an attempt to add um a
waiver process in it you know if similar
to the one that we have in New Hampshire
which allows people to opt out of the
registry or withdraw their
information all right did you have a
question thank you I did so your your
timeliness on the answer regarding opt
out is is profound or is aopo there was
a desire to change from an opin database
sorry an opt out database to an opt-in
database do you have any information on
where in the process that is sure um HB
1606 which accomplished as sort of an
opt-in opt out for the amation registry
uh passed in 2022 and the department is
in the final process of filing our rules
based on H
hp37 our final filing on those rules to
update the legislation are going to be
filed at the end of the month and we
have uh reviewed those rules with
representative Lon as well in
January thank you followup so for those
who were inadvertently swept into the
data B the first time and don't want to
participate what happens to that
data so there are options to withdraw
that data uh when the bill became
effective in
2022 um basically it's a pro prospective
bill so moving forward is is the
intended legislation as far as
withdrawal but and withdrawal um is is
certainly a an option for anybody's data
who was entered in without the ability
to opt out during emergency order 19 I
believe it was okay one more followup so
what happens someone says they withdraw
from the database is their name there
and it just says withdrawn what what
information is Left Behind is residual
or is it completely deleted and they are
no longer tracked whatsoever okay so the
best that I can answer that question is
I don't work for the immunization
program but I know that the department
um as a provider for the immunizations
during the um state of emergency under
Hippa are have to keep information for
seven years as a provider so my
understanding that that information is
taken out of the registry and is held in
a complet uh um hipa compliant area
paper files um until that seven years is
up and then those records are no longer
with the Department okay thank you thank
you so representative Leon did did did
did we get the amendment from OS um we
don't have an official Amendment but I
have the language that I sent so I can
give that to you guys so we can take a
look and see I i' i' rather just wait
and distribute what o OS gives us so so
we can probably just anticipate
deferring
1669 for full action next week um yes I
my question the point of the amendment
was to instead of saying that the
department shall not share it would be
simply to state that prior to entering
into an agreement to share it then the
department would need to follow the
these procedures that way we're not
burdening the budget this year with the
need to do this and build bu up this
this infrastructure when we're not
certain as to when they would actually
look to share this information given
that it's not a department
priority so I don't know if that would
change the it requirements if it said
that um said that prior to entering into
an agreement you need to make sure that
you will be able to actually follow the
withdrawals and um that are allowed um
basically basically saying that it that
uh you won't share it until you're going
to follow existing state law would that
change what the it requirements would be
for this bill and the fiscal
note yes essentially that would make
make it so that the it requirements
would be outside of the bill we would
still need to change the system and
incur costs it just wouldn't be
associated with the bill at this point
as a followup um so as a followup that
actually would just be capturing some of
the cost that came with um with the
previous House Bill 16006 within the
withdrawal that it NE wasn't necessarily
handled within the build out of the IIs
that you'd be able to withdraw that
information not just within the state
but from the
[Music]
IIs um the so the best I can answer on
that is there are um I believe it's a
very delicate system it's very U there's
a lot of tech technology upgrades and
testing and implementation ongoing
maintenance so referencing in the bill
as opposed to I mean the bill is amended
still did require 6080 $80,000 sort of
enhancement I could we could get back to
you probably on on how the amendment
might change change that but I I can
speak that that I can imagine that it
may need uh once you do Implement um
data sharing with States you will you
will incur the cost sorry and then one
last followup do you need statutory
authorization to share that in enter
into those contracts to share that
information with other states or is that
something that is if if you could let me
know where that's delegated to allow the
department to share that information
without um coming to the legislature I'd
be very interested in that sure I I
believe that a lot of our contractual
data sharing is through anou or Ana but
I can certainly get back to you on that
information thank
youou so so Mr weers I I I stopped you
as you were rolling out your your longer
answer uh and if you could just focus on
um based on your analysis uh are there
any other bills that we should be
changing effective dates to so that you
can fully implement the system and
support the the policy or are there any
changes to the dollar estimates if you
could could just focus us on yes there
are changes or no there aren't
changes sir certainly Mr chair um thank
you um the only other one would be HB
1588 we would have a request for a
change for effective date um as a result
of a change to a
system go go ahead and tell tell us what
the that is it's probably in your write
up but so for for HB 1588 in order for
for the Department to be able to make
the changes effectively we would need um
an effective date of July 1st 2025 in
order to go through the contract
Amendment Contracting process yeah and
do the design development and
implementation associated with
it okay so so that change in the date
doesn't change your your your financial
need no it does not all
right anything else on the it area that
is all I have have today okay um I hey I
appreciate the extra work you put in on
this and uh and coming back and sitting
here for so long today thank you for the
opportunity are there any it questions
go ahead um I just wanted to say that
the actual amendment is up there I'll
grab the printed copy just so that
people have something to work to before
you um come back to
1669 should step out okay or we could
just email it later you know because I
don't think think we have time to deal
with it today so it's not time sensitive
but thank you okay thank you thank you
so much so um so I effectively uh ended
1669 for today and we're going to go
ahead and probably try to wrap it up
Monday with the
amendment um and then the last one that
we have to talk about is
1588 relative to court jurisdiction over
persons receiving special education
have we ground everyone down is is there
anyone in the audience that wants to
talk about
1588 are there is there anyone in
division three what what what was our
issue here my notes say this needed two
um two two or three additional DHHS
employees it assumes 32 new clients and
somebody emailed us saying it's probably
really 22
and then the fiscal note was rather
broad from 1.65 million to
5.76 million and so Mr White if you if
you could tell us what you think about
the clientele number and and if the
range on the fiscal note is any tighter
than you thought sure um so I am not as
well versed on the specific population
but in the fiscal note um as introduced
uh dated
12223 if you turn to the second page of
the fiscal note um you will see the
range um that the chair is referencing
there and we're assuming that because
we're expanding the eligibility by a
year we would see an increase in the
total population and as a result of that
we would probably see um the range
potentially the ranges of residential
care foster care Community Based
Services um W within some reasonable
degree and so you'll see there for State
fiscal year 25 for residential a low of
9915 a high of $915,000 a high of $4
million um we also have a few additional
position costs related to child
protective Ser two child protective
service workers and one jppo position
because we're assuming if we're
expanding the population we're going to
have some additional case load impact
going forward uh which is why we
included those those three position
costs there as well um similar to the
last bill there's a lot of variables
here we don't necessarily know who's
going to age into the system but we know
that there'll be some impact so we
basically just straight lined linear um
the the the the cost for this year into
the years
forward
thank you question um yes thank you Mr
chairman and thank you um does this bill
essentially move the costs that are
currently under local school boards and
local taxpayers into the department when
you look at this residential or am I
completely misunderstanding
this so there are situations in in which
the Lea will pay for residential but I
think that's specific to the educational
component um but then there are cases
uh where children are either in u under
Child Protection or uh coming through
the uh division for um Bureau for mental
health where where those children are
being placed into residential treatment
facilities so you can you will have
children at residential treatment
facilities potentially being um paid for
by the state or an Lea depending on on
the particular situation um so if this
doesn't pass who pays for the $4 million
or or whatever the fiscal no is here
because these kids are these kids being
denied services or right now or are they
being paid by somebody else so so so
this is extending um the eligibility age
from 21 to 22 so so so we're expanding
the population so if this doesn't pass
there's no new cost if it does this is
the estimated range sorry and and the
last followup is we increase the age for
special education in the schools to 22
from 21 so the previous 21 years of age
in this would have been a consistent age
with the um with the educational
requirements for special education and
for these payments right now is there a
Gap where there there are students who
are paid by the department except for
that year from 21 to 22 when it bounces
back to local taxpayers because I know
in my town we had a significant jump in
costs in from that increase from age 21
to
22 I I'm not as familiar um with with
that discussion I'd have to go back and
get an answer for you that would be
really helpful to understand what what's
happened to this uh change from 21 to 22
who's paying now and if that makes sense
to move it to the department even if it
is large and not
budgeted thank you any other questions
for Mr Wier on this bill from division
three I have I have a question for you
Mr Ripple could could you go ahead and
get an amendment on on this to change
the effective
date sure yes so that would be to July
1st
2025 yes sir okay
yep okay all right so I'm hoping that'll
be ready to exact next time we get
together uh any other questions uh I'm
going to if not I'm going to go ahead
and conclude uh the hearing on
1588 and then uh just some some closing
remarks uh thank you Mr White um okay so
we're going to meet again in as division
three Monday afternoon uh we've been
starting at 1:00 and uh today I I I sort
of felt like um if we were trying to
exec some of these things and still had
open hearings on some of these things
that we don't quite have enough time
from 1 to 4:30 and that may be because I
I talk too much or just go go so slow I
think it's CU these are complex issues
but um so is is there anyone who would
have a heartburn starting at noon
Monday just come fed and we'll take a
potty break instead of just forcing
marching everyone through it like we did
today okay uh and then um I'm I'm going
to a after I convene I'm going to ask
the Republicans if we could use your
office Mr chair here uh to see where
we're at and you know talk about what we
think we might be ready to exec next
week and what we think is still a work
in progress so so so uh representative
walner uh we I'm I'm sorry I'm
interrupting you
um okay uh so um if I at some point if
you could have a conversation with me
about about what your thoughts are about
which bills are going to be ripe for
exing and obviously the ones that aren't
ripe still have open issues okay all
right uh anything else for the good of
the community Mr secretary you got
everything got it all it all got it all
hey great work three and a half hours of
this that's super okay so um Mr Ripple
final words of wisdom
okay with that uh division three is uh
done for the day
adjourned